session today I'd like to welcome
representative grassy who's going to be
joining us to fill in for representative
hatch who will be
out for an extended period of time so
welcome to our division you'll find that
we're kind of an unruly bunch in here so
you might fit right in we'll see all
right
so first on our agenda we have New
Hampshire housing you're welcome to come
forward and state your names for the
good morning and thanks for having us
um uh Rob dapas executive director of
New Hampshire housing
and I'm Ben Frost Deputy executive
director of Manchester
we have a few comments to get started if
you'd like sure okay well thank you very
much for having us this morning uh for
those of you who don't know New
Hampshire housing was established by
state law in 1981 when the governor and
legislature at the time saw the need for
uh entity to help meet the housing needs
of the state to the extent that they
weren't being met by the private market
and so we've worked for more than 40
years to do that to run programs uh that
Finance multi-family affordable housing
provide rental assistance help
first-time homebuyers get into their
first homes and otherwise help people to
be consistent with that that mandate
that we were given
I will uh so I'm we're here to speak
about the uh recommended appropriation
that's in Senate Bill 231 uh I'll start
by saying that as an instrumentality of
the state we don't really see it as our
role to advocate for or ask for money
we're not a state agency and we don't
get any operating money uh from the
state but to the extent that the state
sees a need for Solutions uh for
problems that are facing uh Granite
Staters
specific to housing we're here to help
and one of the ways that we help is to
administer the affordable housing fund
so I will just speak for two or three
minutes about four key characteristics
of the affordable housing fund uh to
help I hope inform your decisions
uh so one characteristic of the
affordable housing fund that we
particularly appreciate in doing our
work is its flexibility and I will say
New Hampshire does get money from the
federal government to help Finance
affordable housing and we administer
most of it and we do our darndest to
ensure that it's we make maximum
Effectiveness and impact for every
dollar that comes from the federal
government to New Hampshire for housing
purposes but it's not always easy
because it comes wrapped in all kinds of
layers of bureaucratic regulations and
policy mandates that have been layered
on over the years and it doesn't always
make it a good fit for the work that the
people on the ground are doing to serve
New Hampshire's most vulnerable
residents and that's why some of the
finance some of the projects that we
financed over the years that we think
are most impactful and most squarely
aimed at the needs of the the people who
need it most uh wouldn't have been
possible without the affordable housing
fund and some of those are highlighted
in the handout that we've given you I'll
mention 434 Union Street in Manchester
for people who have experienced
homelessness
um
Sullivan house in Claremont which we did
in partnership with the county for
people exiting incarceration with
substance use disorders I'll also
mention though it's not in the handout
Compass House in Laconia Ruth driven
place in Portsmouth I think that is
there is a picture of that one and
Bridge Street recovery housing in uh
Bennington
again these are very important don't
happen to fit well with Federal funding
and and probably wouldn't have been
possible without the resource that is
the affordable housing fund
second characteristics I want to mention
is recyclability and I'm not exactly
sure if that's a word but what I mean by
it is all affordable housing fund pretty
much goes in as a loan and it's not like
a hard bank loan where if you don't make
your payments every month somebody
starts to foreclose on you no payments
are are due unless the project is
spinning off cash which does happen from
time to time with affordable housing
funds sometimes that's because the owner
or property manager has succeeded in
securing a Federal grant to subsidize
People's rent and the operations of the
property and when that happens when
those properties make money every dollar
of that uh of that cash goes back into
the affordable housing fund to help fund
future affordable housing projects in
the state of New Hampshire and so uh
that's that's probably my favorite thing
about the fund to be honest I think
Appropriations over the years have
totaled something around 62 million
dollars we've deployed substantially
more than that to fund housing in New
Hampshire right now we're averaging uh
something north of a million dollars
maybe it's 1.4 million per year in
repayments that we put right back into
the state and affordable housing
projects
third thing I'll mention is process
we've got a team of housing
professionals with combined centuries of
experience in underwriting and reviewing
affordable housing deals and we ensure
that enough money goes into these deals
to ensure that their well-built
adequately capitalized with reserves to
ensure that they're well kept make their
neighborhoods better they're places that
people are proud to call home but no
more than that and what I mean by that
is no dollar of affordable housing has
been used or would be used to enrich a
project that was going to happen anyway
and that takes a lot of work to ensure
that we can make that statement I'm
we're proud to be able to make it
fourth and final thing I'll mention is
true long-term affordability and by long
term I mean at least 20 years that's
what the statute says it has to be in
practice depending on the other programs
that the properties are making use of
many of uh the properties that we
Finance are affordable to for 40 to 60
years and we have a team of compliance
professionals that go out and check on
the property every year two or three
years to ensure that they're being
managed in compliance with those
commitments
uh by true affordability what I mean is
these are subject to not only rent
restrictions but income restrictions so
it's common for affordable housing
programs to ensure that the rent is
limited to something that's affordable
to people working people people who are
not rich uh this is also uh to ensure
that it's rent these apartments are
actually rented to people who are Income
qualified and I think that's an
important characteristic as well
so once again we really appreciate your
time we'd be happy to answer any
questions if you have them and we hope
I want to add to what Rob said he
mentioned Senate Bill 231 uh that the
same appropriation and language is
included in House Bill 2 on page 20 uh
yeah since you've gone to a house bill
too I I know we have some questions
about
invest New Hampshire and then there's uh
number 47 also on page 20.
the affordable housing fund how to do
those two impact you at all do you get
any of your funding from those two
sources or those proposed to sources
because they're both general fund
Appropriations this time
so invest New Hampshire is I guess
similar in purpose but different in
terms of the administration of the fund
that's not administered by New Hampshire
housing that's the beer uh uh division
of business and economic Affairs that
administers those funds so if you're not
Central but that can be used for
affordable housing too right yes I can
that's what I thought
and then the other question was which
respects to line 69 the affordable
housing fund is that I'm sorry 25
million on line 40 or line seven
section 47. yeah so that's that's the
affordable housing fund and I I spent
all my time talking about the affordable
housing fund which is the fund that New
Hampshire housing administers
so the comments that I made are specific
to to that 25 million dollar
appropriation and may not be applicable
to the contemplated invest NH
appropriation or the other elements of
the bill
so you mentioned that so far most of
your not all your funding has been
Federal but this would be General funds
the 25 000 that you would have access to
I wouldn't say that uh most of our I
mean I would say yes most of our funding
but not all of our funding so the
affordable housing fund was created soon
after New Hampshire housing was created
and has received Appropriations from
time to time over the years totaling uh
is it 62 million dollars
all right representative Sweeney I
believe has a question thank you very
much Mr chairman thank you both for
being here today I have a curiosity
mainly on the projects that you do
Finance
say if a developer wanted to build the
first floor as retail and then floors
two through five are going to be
affordable housing
do you work with the developer on saying
okay we're going to help Finance the
construction of two through five and
you're on your own for floor one or is
it strictly just buildings that are all
housing you know that kind of mixed use
uh is allowed and so Bradley Commons and
Dover uh there's one in uh uh Nashua
that's under construction now those are
projects generally there's a condominium
structure so they get a commercial loan
for the commercial space and then we
just Finance the housing portion of it
follow-up and maybe a rough estimation
in your view what what's the number of
missing units that we have in New
Hampshire to meet our demand
we are about to release a Statewide
housing needs assessment so we've been
working on for the past year and that
will indicate that we we estimate that
there is a current shortage that is to
meet current demand of about 23 000
units Statewide that does not account
for future growth and future need that's
just current need
representative Griffin followed by
representative McGuire
you guys seem to have
the statistics on housing in the state
I'm sure you study them closely
I served on a now defunct commission
called uh
the
commission on New Hampshire demographics
and part of that Commission
looked at housing
and a few years ago
this legislative
passed the law
that um
provided for accessory dwellings
on the I guess some of the theory that
people would build an accessory drowling
dwelling maybe for their in-laws
and in time that accessory dwelling
might might end up being affordable
housing do you have any statistics of at
all on whether that theory has been
successful or not intuitively it seems
like it should have been successful
uh
representative this is an excellent
question and the the answer is yes and
no
um the the yes part of it is that we
hear a lot from different communities
about what is happening there so places
like Portsmouth and Merrimack and Dover
they tell us what the the permitting is
that's going on with accessory dwelling
units but there's no Central repository
in the State uh for these kinds of
Records you'd have to go to each
municipality and look at their building
permit uh data and sometimes that's
available in their annual reports but
it's not universally available the
office of planning and development in
the Department of Business and economic
Affairs does do an annual Municipal
survey and they ask municipalities about
their ordinances but they don't ask them
about the building permits that are
issued pursuant to those ordinances so I
think I think you're right that
intuitively we would say it has had an
impact but we don't have really hard
numbers on it yet this but this is this
question keeps coming up and we
recognize that it would be helpful if we
could do some more research on this and
well that's that's kind of what I
thought and I thought by asking the
question I might
stimulate the interests to get an answer
thank you so noted
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman so I'm the invest and the H
when when those folks were here we asked
them specifically could the same develop
or apply for both sets of funds and they
said yes do you have any reason to say
no
I don't that's true
I see and so would that affect the
amount that if you knew somebody was
getting these other funds would that
affect what how much you give them of
your funds or exactly yes and that's
that's the underwriting process that I
referred to when I was talking about our
process so we would uh reserve a certain
amount of funds if that developer went
out and got money from any other source
including invest NH prior to closing on
the real estate transaction we would
review their sources of funds and
there's no way to hide them and we would
reduce the amount of public subsidy that
is going into that into that project I
mean we see that as an important part of
our our responsibility as stewards of
so would there be any gain if all the
money was in one program or the other as
opposed to this kind of scattered
method
I mean they're both grants right they're
both
for similar purposes well ours are not
technically grants they're loans that
are recycled back into the affordable
housing fund oh I see uh so whether
there's a benefit to you know putting
all the money into one versus another uh
I'm not sure if that's sort of a policy
decision for New Hampshire housing to
really weigh in on I mean I guess I
would say that they're aimed at
overlapping but slightly different
problems where the invest NH funds have
less uh Less in the way of affordability
requirements on them and so I think
you're unlikely to see invest in age
financing something like
um you know the recovery housing the
housing for people who are exiting
incarceration or who have experienced
homelessness uh it's pretty much all
sort of higher uh higher income but but
still with some restrictions on it
and as I said there's overlap
um and representative require one thing
I would add is that that the the way
these two programs have been
administered is somewhat different for
one statutorily the affordable housing
fund was created by the legislature in
1988. we are allowed to do grants or
loans we only do loans because we
recognize the importance of bringing
that money back and reusing it and we've
done a substantial amount of that
um the the other thing is that
um that the targeting is different so as
as Rob said uh invest in h it applies to
a much uh greater range of incomes we
are limited by what you have told us in
statute uh we can use the the affordable
housing fund for
and invest in H has used that as Bea has
used the invest NH funding from arpa uh
to essentially Move Along projects that
are already well on their way they're
essentially shovel ready we use the
affordable housing fund to
finance projects from the beginning that
probably otherwise would not happen
listen
thank you further yes so if we did not
give you this 25 million since you have
loan funds and they're being paid back
you're going to make new loans yeah so
how much what would your activity be uh
over the biennium
would be substantially less I mean we
would still have access to the federal
housing tax credit and other federal
funds but you know I think that we uh in
a typical year Finance 500 to a thousand
new units and that wide variability just
has to do with timing and the long
gestation period for multi-family
housing I would say without this 25
million dollars we would be a lot closer
to the 500 or somewhere south of 500
whereas with it I think we could uh be
much closer to the 1000 units Finance
yeah I guess I guess the question is
what's the balance that you have
available to loan right right now uh
it's about five hundred thousand dollars
oh I see so as soon as you get a dollar
you will own it yes yeah I mean we have
a robust pipeline of developers who want
to develop affordable housing but the
resources aren't there we're well
oversubscribed in terms of uh projects
let me ask it a different way how much
how many how much repayment are you
getting every year
uh so it's is it 1.4 million that we
looked at over the last few years seven
years the average over the last seven
years is about 1.4 million yeah oh very
tiny
I don't know if you say it's tiny keep
in mind that over the last 30 plus years
we've received Appropriations totaling
62 million dollars so it's not like
we've received 25 million dollars in
each appropriation and I would also say
because we underwrite these pretty
rigorously it is not typical for them to
spin off a lot of cash it's only when
they do that some of that cash comes
back into the affordable housing fund so
I wish that it were the kind of
revolving Loan Fund that was truly
self-sufficient and you could just get
it up and right are you saying it's not
a mortgage
it is it we have a mortgage and a lien
on the property and we use that to uh
sort of enforce the affordability but we
do not it's not the kind of Home
Mortgage that I have where I make a
payment to the bank every month and if I
don't they foreclose on me
that is to say it's non-amortizing yes
we don't expect regular payments on the
mortgage but the mortgage as an
instrument is there to protect our but
there's not a fixed term of 20 years or
something and and you're going to get
the whole thing in that period of time
the law requires us to have a fixed term
of at least 20 years so we do have that
uh but they it as Rob said sometimes
there's cash in the project and we will
take a portion of that and sometimes the
projects are refinanced at which time
the money would come back to the
affordable housing Fund in full okay
thank you
representative Griffin please thank you
Mr chair for
thank you for taking another question
um
did I hear you correctly to say that you
believe that this section 47 is a mirror
it it is representative uh the and I'll
note that there is a an amendment that
Senate Finance has right now which we
expect to move forward the amendment is
has been proffered by Senators Rosenwald
and Ennis uh that would change the bill
as introduced to reflect that it should
be the funds the 25 million would be
coming out of FY 23 Surplus as is shown
in house bill 2. so the Senate bill as
introduced had it coming out of the the
upcoming biennium this would be coming
out of surplus so it's not a duplication
I take it right this this 25 million is
the same 25 million the senates talking
about we expect both Chambers to treat
Melissa we don't need it today but if
you get us a copy of 231 please at some
point
sure would you like paper copies I
believe I sent it out yesterday oh I
didn't happen to see it with all the
hundreds of emails that we received
do with that okay
so I have a
a quick question where did the 25
million dollars come from because one of
your responses to representative
McGuire's question was you have about
500 000 in there now I believe which
isn't a lot of money so I'm curious why
the ask of 25 million do you have a
place for that or is that just a number
that you thought might be a good number
to choose
well we did not come up with a number
so we we do not ask the legislature for
funding that's the role of advocacy
organizations and legislators who are
interested in this uh we understand that
the the governor put it in into his
budget so we'll take him as a strong
advocate for this
um and we recognize that the Senate is
is looking at this the same way
um so we it would go to the affordable
housing fund which is a specific Fund in
statute administered by New Hampshire
housing so your group specifically
didn't obviously Lobby for this with the
governor as something that somebody else
did I guess correct okay
Mr chair to your question about whether
we have a place for it we certainly do I
mean we have a pipeline that would is
nearly double this in terms of projects
that are on the boards and waiting to go
forward not every one of them will
sometimes they hit snags with permitting
or other construction costs that are
higher than they expected but over the
biennium I'm certain that we will have
places for all of it
I guess what I was looking for is if you
had more of a specific number if you had
say 10 000 units that were out there to
be supported by you folks or you had 2
000. we're wrestling with obviously we
don't have enough money to give to
everybody that's asking so we're just
trying to get a firm figure from folks
so what they really might need versus
what they hope they might be
I understand represent Maguire thank you
Mr chairman so you said you started in
1988 correct 1981 is when our
organization was uh 1991. so we're
talking 40 years
you've you've invested 62 million over
40 years
right so that's a run rate of more like
a million and a half a year it's not
nothing like 25 million over two years
but you say you've got way more projects
than 25 million so how is that possible
I mean your normal rate is a little
well we we have funding sources beyond
the affordable housing fund so Rob
mentioned the low income housing tax
credit which is a federal program and
where this the state's agent for the U.S
treasury in that program that's the
principal source of developing capital
for affordable housing rental affordable
housing in New Hampshire and Nationwide
and we receive also Federal block grants
for similar purposes so there there are
other funding sources the return rate is
not something that we we count on it's
it's something that just happens on a
kind of an ad hoc basis depending upon
the condition of any particular
development so some years it may be zero
in other years it may be double uh 1.4
it varies considerably that's that's
just an average over the past seven
years of returns
foreign
if I may representative I would say also
that
we're in a housing crisis now that we
weren't in 25 or 35 years ago and so the
need for public investment in meeting
the needs in terms of housing Supply uh
is is uh there's a clearer case for it
now I guess than there was a few decades
ago man sure so how much money has the
federal government put in over those 40
years
I don't know that we've tallied that but
we could do that and get that number for
you okay so it's a big number is that
what we're saying yeah much bigger than
62 million yes and representative
McGuire I I would also point out that in
the preceding biennium uh uh the
affordable housing fund was appropriated
25 million
we anticipated using that over two years
and in fact we used it in the first year
of its utilization because the need was
so great
okay thank you
additional questions from the division I
do have one I guess as a follow-up to
representative McGuire
how is this the first time I'm sure it's
not but I never like to assume this is a
fairly substantial ask the 25 million
dollars what have you received from the
state in the past as far as general fund
dollars towards this fund do you know
the um
the the number 62 million 62.6 million
total Appropriations to the affordable
housing fund since it was created in
1988. that's all that was all General
funds it there there I I have a tally
but I did not bring it with me but some
of it was bonded and was in House Bill
25 in in any budget year there were a
couple of off-budget Appropriations
um I think one of those was a bond uh
you know wrapped into other things the
state was bonding for as well at the
same time
um do those generally go through uh
public works because we've had some
discussion within the division a number
of these items that we're seeing this
year had historically gone to Public
Works which has a threshold top of about
120 million dollars that they have to
work with so I'm guessing all this came
here because the fire exceeded their
threshold well I'm just curious why this
may not have gone to public works first
or maybe again
I think the the point is that anytime
it's bonded yeah anytime anytime it is
proposed to be uh in a bond it goes to
public works first
and then comes here uh whenever it's not
included as part of a bond it comes to
the finance committee first
and that's not always true but
well it in our in our experience it
should but it's not always true in our
experience that has been the pattern
with these Appropriations to the
affordable housing fund okay for the
affordable but we've seen a lot of
things come there go here we had the
chairman of Public Works here just the
other day because there was some
crossover that we wanted to try to
address so
represent grassy
yes thank you Mr
um question I have is you know when we
talk about how much money that you're
you're getting here and compared to what
you've got in previous years you said
there's a shortage of about 23 000 units
that we have in the state of New
Hampshire over the Latin number of years
that you've been in existence how many
units annually do you bring online
well it's more annually now than it was
earlier in our uh earlier in our history
uh right now as I said it's 500 to 1000
per year in our 40-year history I think
we've uh financed something around 17
000 units about 15 000 or still of which
are still in our portfolio and still
affordable so you you say you bring on
annually you've probably averaged about
between 500 and a thousand units per
year and we've got a 23 000 unit
shortage so that's why this money is
looking to try to put a dent in that and
if I remember one of the comments you
made you could probably with this money
there's a chance you could do half that
those number of units so we could
probably be looking at about 11
000 units coming on based on the amount
of money that you have here that's I
mean that's a big ask but that certainly
would address a substantial uh you know
going to its addressing the need that we
have
I think we would not be able to create
11 000 units with with this funding uh
it would be substantially less than that
uh it it you know it contributes toward
solving the problem but it is not alone
the solution
thank you
so as a follow-up to that
um The Realistic figure you're saying
about a thousand units is your hope or
goal or so what do you have any idea
what that would cost as far as
well let me tell you why it's difficult
I know it's difficult because of the
size of the units where the units are
and all that but just a guesstimation
It's Not Unusual for us to need a
hundred thousand dollars of public
subsidy to make an affordable housing a
permanently affordable housing uh unit
uh to bring it into existence now I will
representative McGuire asked a question
earlier about whether invest in age
could be combined with this fund These
funds and so that's a big variable if 30
million dollars of invest in each money
is available and a substantial portion
of these projects are availing
themselves at both there may be fifty
thousand dollars of affordable housing
fund going into that project and it
might kind of look like we're creating
twice as many units but obviously a
dollar public subsidy is a dollar public
subsidy
hey thank you uh
not seeing any further questions so
we'll take a look at this and take a
look at the Senate bill as well and see
how they correspond
House Bill 46 which is new to the
division we haven't seen this before
this is establishing a committee to
study replacement of bail Commissioners
with court
magistrates do we have a copy of that 46
Mr Hoffman we do not the last one has
49.
so those guys
don't seem very good at getting paid
back right I mean if I loaned out 60
million dollars I'm sure you'd get paid
back you'd get paid back you wouldn't
get paid back a million and a half a
year
we'll open up the work session on House
Bill 436 I see the prime sponsor is here
we'd like to
there you go make sure you turn the mic
on there you go yes
my name is Linda Harrier gathwaite I'm a
representative from Nashville New
Hampshire
um Hills 10 Ward 9. and I'm here to
and this is my first time before you so
I have no clue oh no no not to worry
we're we're fairly nice sometimes uh Mr
Hoffman do you have the docket held
this made it through the house and the
I'm sorry represent we usually
try to get a little history first and
okay
I hate to assume but I would have
thought it went to
well that's what
to be honest with you I thought attorney
head would be here and I text him and he
said it was no physical impact so
Mr Hoffman
the bill was referred to criminal
justice and Public Safety and the
committee report was ought to pass with
amendment by a vote of 20-0 and that
Amendment
which is in front of you now passed on
representative Sweeney so so Mr Hoffman
with the original version of the bill
did that have a fiscal impact yes and
questions for the prime sponsor
representative McGuire um
not really I'm sorry not for you I just
I think we should simply say off the
pass
um but I do notice two typos on line ten
so maybe we nine ten yeah
um this sentence the committee shall
evaluate whether bail commissioner
should be replaced or supplemented by
Court magistrates and assess the
following so it should be bail
Commissioners should be replaced
right or something
that's all okay thank you yeah so maybe
we make a little a little amendment to
fix that sentence and just say off the
past if that makes sense
it's uh been moved I Believe by
representative McGuire with those two
grammatical Corrections is it seconded
represent a Sweeney
okay
Mr chairman yes discussion
yeah this is a this bill is uh
something that's been kicking around in
the court system for quite some time and
I believe I don't know whether I saw it
in the in the court system budget or
somewhere along the line uh in this
session I saw a
a bill of provisions and a bill that
actually accomplished what's in this
study committee and I think the probably
the reason the study committee is being
proposed is because they may have run
into some problems as far as getting
getting it done because there is
there is a fair amount of cost involved
in accomplishing what this what this
bill
would result in if the if the study
committee uh examined into the the cost
of
creating a magistrates and also the
logistics involved in the bail system
I would have to completely revamp the
bail system because of the present time
uh it's run well it's run locally not at
State funds that work out but bail
Commissioners work locally and are
generally under the supervision of the
district court system
and the spirit court gets involved to
some degree but most of the most of the
bail issues are started in the district
court system because they start when
maybe we can put you on this committee
representative
well there's a line of fiscal impact the
so it has been moved and seconded our
clerk is not here so we'll just
yeah
oh I went I was looking over here and
okay thanks representative Sweeney when
you're ready if you could please call
the roll and representative McGuire's
motion yep so this is on House Bill 46
FN motion uh we're just doing auto fast
as amended yep motion is not to pass as
amended representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
perfect votes temporary clerk not taking
that job votes yes uh percent of cameras
is not here representative grassy yes
Representative hewock no
okay
and Cameron is on here and Mr chairman
yes okay
five to one
all right moving right along Mr Hoffman
moving right along uh Mr Hoffman you
have a number of documents I know to
Melissa Mr hoppen are very busy they've
got a status documents for us
and some other things
maybe we can start with the revenue not
sure two Hospital one back budget
okay
Mike or Melissa whatever you want to
let's take a look at the back of the
quite a bit of this
actually most of this
reappears every every two years
um describes all the footnotes that you
see in the budget as you flip through it
the letter footnotes
um
used to be assigned to various class
lines
um so for example
um
footnote f
identifies that that's an appropriation
that doesn't elapse in the first year
and is available for the two years of
biennium
G restricts the use of a particular line
so that it cannot be
transferred or used for anything else so
you may see that in things like
utilities
and then a B and H used to be used but
footnote I you'll see with other sources
of revenue
to ensure that if the revenue doesn't
come in agencies don't don't spend
section two that's something that
um division two will deal with regarding
University system accounts and Community
has to do with the assignment of Office
Space
a department of administrative Services
manages the office space and
if such state-owned space is available
they try to make sure that agencies
using state-owned space before they go
Lottery Commission is another
then Section 5 all of the positions that
are no longer needed and abolished in
this case
um
the governor's budget or Hospital want
to introduce are listed here
and those positions go away permanently
as opposed to being just unfunded
so anything that's authorized that's on
the abolished list
can never be filled again they would
have to seek new positions through
represent Maguire followed by
representative Griffin so if a position
is existing but unfunded sometimes the
the commissioner or whoever can shift
money into that unfunded and then hire
somebody is that right certain
Commissioners have that Authority like
Health and Human Services and it may be
one or two others Corrections
allows them flexibility but anytime you
see that language it also includes the
sentence as long as they don't exceed
their Appropriations for salaries and
benefits
right so if somebody some other position
was funded but didn't have a person for
a long time they might decide to
to move it into some other position
right right yeah or if if the
commissioner
has vacancies
this one's funded but I don't need it
they really need this one right they're
allowed to do that all right thank you
representative Griffin are any of these
funded
most likely not and if they were the
governor would have already accounted
section 6 appears every year and
the Health and Human Services Bureau of
Child Support gets assert a certain
amount of money to send to the courts
to provide that they can
process
child support orders and and services in
a timely manner
and this is
as long as I can remember this section
then seven shows you the governor's
recommended
unrestricted revenues for the general
fund and the education trust fund
then on the back you have the highway
and Fish and Game fund
the other handout is from house Ways and
Means
and that is the
house unrestricted revenues
so similar sections the back of the
budget
for the bill introduced includes
Governor's Revenue estimate and the
document that you have with
representative Weiler as a sponsor is
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman so the main difference between
these two other than the specific
numbers is the new one contains the
communication tax right that's still
taken out in House Bill 2 so maybe we
shouldn't put it back into how spill one
the uh the way Ways and Means presents
these is based on current law
so whatever happens whether the
communications tax stays in or comes out
you'll see on the Surplus schedule
that Mike Kane prepares you'll have your
base revenues
and then he has scheduled two
adjustments adjustments to revenue so
we'll have another line on the Surplus
that shows Revenue adjustments
so right now the governor's budget
communication tax is out if the house
leaves it in Mike Kane will have a
surplus adjustment to reflect that
right but I mean this amendment 0868
has the communication tax so if we
adopted this amendment all of a sudden
one and two House Bill one and House
Bill two don't match anymore
I think
you were you would be agreeing with Ways
and Means up to this point in time yeah
and then the house still has the option
of deciding What Becomes of the
communication Services tax okay so when
if we left it out you would we would
have another amendment to this section
right that would yeah okay
because that's about what 56 million
over the biennium
a substantial amount of money but yeah
yeah
yeah they'd have to go after those that
were delinquent and chase people that
all right we'll just take a quick three
minute break and start at 10 30 on House
again
my ways and means on the revenue figures
where the norm major Susan only whoever
would come in but we don't have to do
that we can accept what the house took
up yesterday and just accept their
numbers and use it as our Baseline so
are you okay with that represent McGuire
okay I mean revenues our thing because
so miss representative McGuire will move
to we just accept the
Revenue figures that have been presented
to us by Ways and Means correct
and it's seconded by representative
Griffin
and seeing no more discussion we'll just
have a show a hand so Mike and put it in
his book all in favor
opposed okay Mike you got your vote so
all right moving to uh House Bill 36
we've had a number of work sessions on
this I know the division is looking for
additional information Marty if you like
to
bill as well I don't know if you want to
all right uh do we have that Amendment
while we're in break
Mr Hoffman did have a handout from the
New Hampshire retirement system as a
letter dated November 8th that was
sent to me and
on this bill and I want to make sure all
an additional handout behind that
earnable compensation
someone like to speak to the amendment
future
um Melissa could you maybe make another
47.
foreign
as soon as you have a copy
I believe we're ready president Pearson
fantastic thank you Mr chair for the
record Representative Steve Pearson
Rockingham District 13 which encompasses
the town of Derry
and I am an active member of the New
Hampshire Retirement System
zero eight
nine one h
uh
removes something from the original bill
that apparently the actuaries have lost
sleepover
and has made
the original Bill calls for a one and a
quarter percent increase in the hard
pension cap annually that was done to
keep up with inflation
um
added cost to the bill it has certainly
added stress to the actuaries and trying
to determine what all that means
so in the interest of making this work
better it was struck out in the
amendment
so the hard 125 000 hard cap will just
be the hard cap it won't it won't adjust
it won't increase the
the legislature someday could address
that if they need to if it's a problem
but that
um
in the interest of making things better
for
for the bill and for the ability for
forecasting that that was the precipice
all right questions representative
Sweeney thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being here to take the question so
if we were to adopt this amendment what
would the new fiscal note roughly
estimate say for the bill
that's why representative Pearson asked
me to join him up here for the record
Marty Carlin representing nhrs we don't
have a position on the bill one way or
the other but because of the complicated
nature representative Peterson I thought
it might make sense to get up together
because
um some questions he may be able to
answer and some and I may be uh so so
essentially the
um increase to the maximum benefit limit
and the 1.25 escalator going forward
added um cost both to the normal cost
and to the unfunded liability piece for
this bill
um on the normal cost side it was about
you know 0.12 percent of pay to 0.22 and
on the unfunded side it was about 0.25
to 0.5 and these These are rough numbers
um you know from the actual they haven't
valued this amendment or change or
anything but by way of illustration the
the covered payroll
um for group two police and fire and
fiscal 22 was about 483 million dollars
so if this change were to lower the
employer rate impact by one percent of
pay okay and that it may be lower than
that that's that's sort of a high-end
estimate that would cut off the annual
employer contributions about 4.8 million
dollars so it would it would reduce it
you know in fiscal 26. you know by any
again these aren't down to the penny
numbers this is this is a rough ballpark
if the normal if the
if the if the elimination of the
escalator or whatever you would call the
1.25 is less than that it's going to be
less but on an optimistic end it's 4.8
maybe at 0.75 off the rate it'd be about
3.6 you know but we're talking Millions
a year
but for eliminating that
follow-up yes thank you Mr chairman in
the original fiscal note
we see fiscal year 25 had a 25 million
dollar appropriation uh but combined for
24 and 25 the expenditure was 165 000
for the state and then uh indeterminable
for
political subdivisions in 24 and 25 but
then in 26 with another 25 million
appropriation from the state uh 3.28
million from expenditures from the state
but then a 13 13 million eight hundred
and sixty thousand dollar expenditure
from the political subdivision so this
amendment would it lower
the state expenditures or the political
subdivisions expenditure it would lower
both
um you know uh you know proportionally
so you know the political subdivision
projected cost just for the police and
Fireside in uh 26 so like 11.5 million
and the States was 2.88 so you know it
would you know it as a on a proportional
basis the reduction would be the same in
both lines
follow-up yes thank you thank you again
Mr thank you for being here take your
questions I'll I'll make sort of a
pre-request that if we were to adopt
this amendment could you get us the
spreadsheet for the next 10 years of the
bill as to what you expect expenditures
from the state and the political
subdivisions to be over each fiscal year
because we our fiscal no caps at 26.
yeah but if we're going to fiscal year
2033 in this bill I'd just like to see
all the numbers laid out yeah so so
um that that's something the actuary
would have to run it's it's still an
unapproved Amendment I'm not sure if we
could pull that off but as a way to
think about the cost going forward okay
there's the and I think some of the
confusion sometimes it comes up when we
talk about some of these nhrs bills and
the percents is that there's two percent
two percentages we're talking about
usually you folks deal with the bottom
line number it's a million dollars next
year it's 1.1 it's a 10 increase
our rates are calculated as a percent of
the covered payroll so that's that's one
percent right you know so if your
payroll is a million dollars and the
rates ten percent you're paying a
hundred thousand dollars in
contributions you know but if that
yeah but the difference between what the
rates are and what the rates are been
you know that if the rates went from 30
to 33 percent
two different sets of percentages and I
think that that sometimes muddies the
waters and I don't know if we're clear
enough on
explaining that properly but with the
the fiscal 26 numbers okay with the bill
as currently adopted by the house not
with this amendment that you know
13 or 14 million uh you know for for 26.
basically you could roll that forward at
2.75 increases for the next 10 years to
to project what it it's going to cost
that that's the payroll growth the
inflation assumption for
um group two salaries maybe maybe you
know somebody make little that's too low
or too high but that's what the current
Actuarial assumption is that payroll
will grow you know um two point seven
five percent a year so that
um number in the fiscal note
um again you could roll that out at
times you know 1.0275 for 10 years to
see what the cost would look like
um
further questions represent Maguire
thank you Mr chairman
is this section
um RSA 100a's colon 6-5
only for group two or does it imply for
everybody uh this I everyone yeah so so
yeah there is a maximum benefit limit of
120 000 for all groups both groups right
now and this would just increase it for
both as well
okay so to increase it for both yeah
um follow-up yeah and it would also do
this 2001 to 2011 thing for group one
employees as well
yes it it it yeah right right now those
members anybody who was hired before or
7109 and hadn't hadn't been invested but
um or you know it wasn't were invested
by one one of twelve that you know they
don't that you had to have been hired by
seven one of o nine right now so the
people in hired in them both three four
five six there is no maximum benefit cap
right now on those members
um
right yeah so may I follow so what I'm
talking about is Part B Part B of the of
this section five
um currently as I understand it they're
limited to 85 percent of their final
compensation
right and so this is changing it to 100
of their final compensation as a maximum
yes whichever is the lesser the 125 or
the 100 let's say somebody's final
compensation was yeah was a hundred or
so yeah just to make it an easy number
right so then there they would currently
have a maximum of 85 000.
and this bill would let them have a
maximum of a hundred yeah yeah but I
guess
maybe we assume in group one there's
hardly any effect because the divisor is
66 so you'd have to work 66 years in
order to hit the cap right so therefore
it's it's not much of a difference is
that kind of the idea yeah yes
um you know on a quick back of the
envelope
um that I did up in my head right now
for instance somebody who joined group
two
um you know prior to seven one of 11 and
you know but less than four years before
then their multiplier is 2.1 percent so
they would have to work 40 years to get
to 84 of their AFC so then you know so
so you know and it's the closer you get
you know if the 2.4 people they have to
work less but there's a certain amount
of years to which you get the max even
even under you know the old plan right
now
um once uh group two member is working
more than 40 years and that that's rare
but not not
um it does happen
um you know they they basically have
maxed out what their pension is going to
be they don't they no longer contribute
anymore the the employer still kicks in
uh while they're working but you know so
once somebody right now under this law
once they would have gotten to 85 30
years from now you know um you know they
would max out but this this does bring
it to a hundred so
um you know there's two things at play
here you know you don't see those
numbers a lot right now but with
inflation 10 20 years down the road
um you know 125 you know maybe more of a
normal number than it you know it seems
crazy now but you know what did we all
start working at you know 20 30 years
ago for our annual salary compared to
now
thank you for and that's that's the
financial part about the policy part of
that
and I
wear that 85 to 100 came from was the
idea of Representative Carol McGuire
so
uh
I'm just telling you that was that was
it her idea that partially that was done
to deal with just inflation
right so that was the precipice of that
thing
although I've seen the two of them
disagree on stuff so
yeah absolutely sure yeah my father and
I don't have a identical voting record
either
so I guess a concern I have now we
haven't looked at this amendment as far
as its Financial impact but
I
sent out the bill to my community of
Peterborough just to see what type of
impact
the original bill would have and it was
about forty one thousand dollars a year
on a very small town with a very small
Police and Fire Department
so I guess what I would like to see
is representative Sweeney also requested
if we could have a breakdown of the
municipal impacts
um
before we really at least in my opinion
move this forward because it's a
substantial impact whether it's a
reduction as far as at 25 million a year
for the capital of Chase
so
that would be done in conjunction with
the rate drop that's occurring as well
so you're looking at a potential impact
so there'd be no impact this this
amendment as far as the financial
numbers we've seen yes I mean there's an
impact with the amendment to lower it
absolutely but as far as the impact is
to the community this this this rate in
the rate reduction or coinciding
simultaneously and the ask is less than
the reduction now
so the the overall impact from a
year-to-year budget of you of the
Peterborough fire department would be
nothing
representative Weiler why would it be
why would it be lowered
why would this go down with the removal
of the why why would the the
contribution from the municipalities be
lower because the rate is dropping
eight percent in Fire and seven percent
reduction in PD
I don't understand why we would drop the
rate one with 5.7 billion in the hole
um what what represent representative
Pearson is referring to is the current
employer contribution rates uh for
fiscal 24 25 have already been set
they're um they're taking effect this
July 1st and from compared to the 22 23
rates the fire rate for instance went
down from for the employer side from
32.99 of covered payroll to 30.35 so
that's a you know 2.64 reduction in the
rate the reason the rates went down um
to representative Wilder's point is you
know
um you know the way the rates are
calculated it's based on a five-year
rolling average of the investment
performance in the five-year period
ending June 30th of 21 which was the
rate setting valuation you know we had a
very good five years especially with 21.
so so that
accelerated the payoff of the liability
to the extent that it was able to lower
the rates you know by that you know uh
by those amounts
um you know ideally if all assumptions
are met going forward which is probably
an impossibility you know the rates
would stay at that level through 2039 in
the bulk of the ual is amortized if we
have a bad five-year stretch of
Investments and we're below our assumed
rate of return or if the board
um it chooses to lower the assumed rate
of return because of economic
projections going forward that's going
to put upward pressure on the rate so
you know to representative you know
Pearson's point in in a vacuum you know
in 24 25 you know Peterborough is paying
you know 2.64 less for fire as a percent
of pay is than it is now and this is
would increase it without this amendment
by 2.62 so
but that's in 26 so you know there's you
know what I mean it's there are there
are unknowns you know in that equation
but that you know we did we did see a
rate decrease this year which is good
news
follow-up would be
are you taking that deficit into account
at all when you do this rate setting it
doesn't appear that you are the the the
the overall unfunded deficit
um yeah they are so it's you know you're
always you know the of the 5.7 unfunded
right now five million five billion of
that was accrued before
um
July 1 of 17 which is when the layered
amortization came in so that 5 billion
is scheduled to be paid down as a
percentage of payroll in all four member
groups through this through through
fiscal 39. so we've got you know 16 more
years to pay that off and the rates
are the unfunded portion of the rates
you know are developed backwards from
that how much are we going to need in
2039 and what percent of pay every year
and that that factors in payroll growth
over time as well I mean we don't expect
the payroll to be the same now there's
next year or five or ten years from now
that's going to grow but if the
percentage is the same we'll be taking
in more dollars you know over the over
the subsequent years my recollection is
you didn't have a good five years you
had one good year out of five
uh it well we had we had an
unprecedentedly Good Year like most
individual investors looking at a June
30th year over year in in many pension
plans they're made 29 over 29 which
um May well be the highest return we had
this some years in the 70s and 80s we
can't find data for
um you know you know but you know so
there was but we don't we don't
recognize that all at once oh yeah yeah
um you know we were in the you know we
were in the positive side all five years
and that that and of that 29 in fiscal
21. one one-fifth of that was recognized
in the smoothing you know in the other
four-fifths of it are going to be
recognized fiscal 22 through 26. so in a
sense that was a really good year and it
helped with the five-year performance
but it also puts a little money in the
kitty going forward you know to try to
insulate against you know a year like
last year
um you know the the negative return
um if we're looking get another one of
that you know when you start stringing
together multiple down markets that's
that's when it gets stuff to to hit your
average over five
going back 10. that's not how it
representative Sweeney Mr chairman I
have a procedural question
um for the more experienced members of
the committee can we request a fiscal
note for this amendment without adopting
it or do we have to adopt it in order to
get a fiscal note no we can get a
physical note if we really want one but
it always makes it cleaner for the LBA
to have an amendment
you know represent I mean with typically
we write fiscal notes on amendments that
have been adopted by the whole body
just because there's so many amendments
out there with retirement amendments
it's even more restrictive because the
general fund pays for their Actuarial
work
so yeah a couple of years ago they they
came in there was a bill filed by
someone actually and I think on this
division to require the general fund I
believe it was Kathy McGuire McGuire
Kathy Rogers yeah yeah because she felt
we were taking too much from the
retirement system to find these
actuarials fiscal notes so
but I think before we move forward we
really need a fiscal note right there's
a lot of money here
um
there are a lot of changes I've been
trying to go through the amendment very
quickly to see the changes and I
I'm still having some problems getting
my head around
the change yeah go ahead let me ask
Marty along these lines do you does the
actuary analyze the bills section by
section and therefore say the effect of
section one is X dollars an effective
section two is like that so if we're
thinking about an amendments can we in
our mind say okay if I change section
two maybe it does this right not it
doesn't tend to work that way unless
it's it there's you know they're very
two separate bifurcated changes because
a lot of these most of these changes in
almost all cases they interact with each
other you know the retirement age or the
multiplier so if you change one it's
Gonna Change other aspects of it so they
they doing it as a la carte I I don't
think is is possible you know unless
there was a particular piece of
legislation that does something over
here and something over there you know
you know but these are all interrelated
so to analyze this amendment you can't
just sort of look at section five of the
bill you have to yeah that that was the
you know the the the sort of quote you
know optimistic ballpark answer to
representative Sweeney you know but they
would have to actually you know run the
run the model again with these changes
and then see what it actually comes out
so
um
so the only change that I see in
it's a one-page Amendment but comparing
it to section five in the original bill
as amended by the house it's just that
language and C the maximum benefit shell
increase annually by the 1.25 not that's
the only change BNC B it occurs in B and
C
85 crossed out to 100 on my b yeah
that's correct that there's no change
there the change is the reduction of the
one in a quarter percent annual and that
occurs in two paragraphs yeah yeah I see
it yeah right
but that's the only that is up above as
far as the dates and they're all they
all remain the same correct that's
what's in the original bill that was
passed
so how soon can we get a revised fiscal
note or how soon can you look at this
Marty
yeah we could put a call out today and
then I can get an estimate you know from
them on on um you know when we I can get
something I'm thinking that you know
sometime next week is typically when
there's a rush
you know Amendment you know we you know
just under the normal course under RSA
1444 you know they're asking LBA assets
to flip it in five days so that's always
our goal
so just a follow-up to that question we
know the original Bill had a 25 million
dollar general fund impact for both the
first and second year the biennium and
then carrying through to 2033 I think
yeah
what was the total Municipal impact
to someone the original Bill the dollar
amount well well um oh the overall
dollar amount was 200 203 million for
the municipal impact well no that was
just the cost of the whole bill I'm just
curious about the municipal impact is uh
I'm going to turn to
the gentle lady from the municipal
Association Mrs hack do you
have
could you could you please use the mic
thanks
I believe the original Bill didn't have
a fiscal note um immediately attached
when the bill was introduced and then
the amendment was so quickly introduced
thereafter
um we've been we have been working based
on the amended language
so do you have like a dollar figure that
you folks have come up with as far as a
municipal impact of this legislation
so to quickly answer that we look at
each bill and each policy proposal and
its impact to the municipality and then
we look at the aggregate amount based on
how many bills are passing through the
house and the Senate and right now we
have six bills all with a municipal
impact all having a cumulative impact on
Municipal rates so in a vacuum each bill
decided upon itself will have one effect
but when you each bill that we pass
forward that has another effect will
continue to compound that so well the
assumptions that representative Pearson
and Mr Carlin stated are absolutely the
same as our position it all stays the
same and the actuary analysis the
Investments continue at and the rates of
return are the same this would be the
impact but if changes continue to be
made to the statute in this area or
other areas there will be accumulative
or aggregate impact that is what we
consider for our members so
it's a little bit complicated and I can
send you all of that analysis if you'd
like I just I just I was just looking I
always try to find something simple but
it's simple unfortunately but I was just
really curious if you had put something
together just the impact of this
specific bill as it was drafted as far
as the impact on municipalities that's
all so I know you're saying there's all
these other things but just this
specific one so when we did a very brief
kind of survey of a few members just who
quickly will respond we had similar
results to you there was a high impact
but that didn't take into account for
everything being equal in a in a vacuum
that would be if it was an escalator and
of course what we don't know is salary
increases moving forward in 2026 we
can't predict that because that affects
the retirement rates and our members
were counting on the plan through 2039
to fund the you all so that they can see
their rates go down so every time we add
something
um they can't count count on their rates
going down and in future budgeting and
more sophisticated communities like
Peterborough being one of them it's a
little bit bigger of a town they do that
kind of analysis in future years on to
what the savings might be in their
future budgets so
I think it's a complex issue and it's a
complex policy decision and I'm sorry I
don't have that data on my fingertips
sir all right no problem thanks
so the other question I have for I guess
Marty in the letter you sent out
to me which I've shared with all the
division members you did make a
there was an indication in here that
this would obviously have an impact on
how much
again I know we have another amendment
so that just changes everything up for
us but
well the current bill not putting this
amendment aside the group two portion of
that there was it
um
it was I think it was 13.8 million
unfunded across all the groups six
million of that is attributable to to
group two
um the group one population is much
larger so they pick up a bigger piece of
that
um you know and and you know and of that
six million the actor again this wasn't
a report this was a you know a
conference call you know that you know
would would estimate you know you know
ballpark that the
benefit escalator would add about 0.25
or point between 0.25 and 0.5 to the
percent of payroll
um
so so it you know that it's it's a
it's a real number and it's going to add
up you know when we're talking costs in
the in the millions
um you know but that that's what if
doing a fiscal note on the amendment
would be able to
show the difference you know between the
original and this and that I I
um to the question you had for Miss hack
I mean I do have information available
on the covered payroll for State versus
Municipal group two members so
um you know I could send that
you know how much the municipalities can
you know um payroll for for uh police
and fire is and you know the difference
in this bill with or without the 250
million
um again the original Bill not with the
amendment um it the actuary projected an
increase in um the rate of 2.62 to 2.72
percent for the two groups with the 25
million a year for 10 years and and
without the 25 without any additional
State appropriation you just passed it
and everybody paid their shares those
rates would have been
um
oh you know what I'm talking about
5.96 for police and 6.01 for fire so so
the percent as a percentage of payroll
the employer rates for you know for a
state and local would be more than
double so if you're projecting Municipal
costs without any state funding you know
the the state's um you know picking up
as you know offsetting a significant
portion of the cost that would have been
uh put onto the municipalities you know
through a rate increase over the next
you know 20 or so years
yeah as you I think everybody knows
we're wrestling with uh less money than
the governor told us we had and we have
just in this division hundreds of
millions of dollars collectively that
are impacted by less Revenue so
we're trying to get a better number
because there has been some limited
discussion about
having the municipalities pay this
portion because the state may not have
the 25 million dollars a year and that's
why we'd like to see what the municipal
impact because I know no it would be
substantial yeah I I probably in-house
we could
give you an aggregate number for the
municipalities and maybe run the payroll
of you know 15 or 20 towns of various
sizes to show
um you know some of the impacts you know
because basically once you have once
somebody can pull that data out of the
system for me all you do is multiply it
by the percentage rates here to show
what the extra cost would be you know
that does doesn't require an actuary
all right
further questions from the division
represent McGuire yeah and thank you Mr
chairman so who produced this piece of
paper that was done by nhrs staff that
that just it's a sample
um if if you find it helpful very
um you know we could we could roll it
out for all the different tiers in in
trb as well as the seven one of 11 hires
in in TRC but basically what it did was
it just took the average police and fire
salary you know you know over the last
five years and use that as a high five
or a high three for a theoretical
um group two police member retiring with
22 years of service and shows some of
the differences in the benefit
calculation how the AFC is changed by
using a five versus a three average how
the application of unused sick and
vacation time weather accounts or not
impacts the benefit and how the
multiplier impacts the benefit
um and you know they
it there's also a compensation over base
trigger in the um the trb folks that
could lower that AFC even a little bit
more depending on their
um salary history over the last 10 years
and how that was earned and reported so
so that you know that's another variable
that that's it's an extremely
that that's like pin and Jello to the
wall because it depends on the
individual
um almost to
estimate that so
um thanks can I I'd like to ask some so
I think these kind of examples are very
Illuminating so more of them in would be
better right so okay so let me ask about
the lower left corner here the average
salaries
do you so something weird happened in
fiscal year 22 compared to 21 which is
police jumped by uh four thousand and or
3800 and fire declined by
2400 or something do you have any
explanation of why that happened we have
a theory
um and folks behind me can tell me if
they think it's right or wrong but in in
fiscal 21 which was you know July 1 of
20 through June 30th
um a lot of First Responders primarily
in the fire service were doing coveted
vaccinations and other things across the
state
um you know and you know receiving
compensation for that so I think we were
thinking that's kind of where that that
came in as they were working more hours
and maybe more money that year mainly
because of that
um and isn't the other Factor too is in
the the substantial Staffing shortages
on the police side that increase is
because overtime is beyond through the
roof I mean the Department of
Corrections has expelled their annual
overtime by the they did it by the end
of January so you're gonna you will see
higher numbers in police because they're
being forced to work more
I see do you have figures for average
number of hours worked in these
categories or not really we don't we all
the employers report to us is you know
total compensation you know you know
ProPay period we add it up but you know
we don't get in on an hour later so a
dollar of standard salary and a dollar
of overtime are the same yeah yeah
we charge the same percentage on both
yeah all right thank you
any uh follow-up questions
representative Griffin anything else or
um or is it grassy anything no I I was
hoping to get a lot of answers today but
I think we could uh I think we can work
what I think we've accumulated a lot
uh yes representative Sweeney it's just
to be clear so do we need to vote to
adopt this amendment in order to get the
fiscal analysis
like that's technically not but we can
see this will make everybody happy
well I I would I would make the motion
to adopt 0891h
motion has been made a second I'll
second
adopt and making a very clear statement
that we want the additional financial
information on what this amendment does
when the clerk is ready if he will
please call the roll
unless there are other questions
no
well I was just going to say the
amendment clearly reduces the fiscal
impact of the bill so therefore there's
no reason not for adopted right so yeah
right representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney votes yes
representative grassy yes representative
so Marty will be waiting for your
analysis and anything else you can
we're under a real tight guideline or
deadline look here as you know we've got
to make some decisions very quickly
because we have to present our
recommendations to the full Committee in
another week so
you don't have to get this done
yeah do we have like a calendar or
something those two yeah we'll be
getting that today as well we're getting
so I'm going to ask this question I
probably don't want to hear the answer
when we ask them for a fiscal note on a
retirement bill is that a thousand
dollar thing is it a ten thousand dollar
thing what is it the way this statute is
written is the retirement system
collects the costs and charges back to
the state and the governor can issue a
warrant out of the general fund
so I guess it depends on the bill and
how much work they have to do what we'll
do is because it hasn't passed the full
body
we'll put something together with
Marty's information and we call it a
fiscal analysis it doesn't attach to the
bill but if nothing changes after the
bill passes the house
same information will go into a fiscal
level
so whatever is your pleasure if you'd
like to use whatever document
they have we can we can do amendments
saying that we've looked at it and don't
disagree but you could also just accept
what the retirement system
presents Marty do you have a better
answer
um I it was the question about the cost
the cost of a fiscal note you know on a
sort of normal bill
um typically the cost runs between about
twenty five hundred and seven thousand
depending on the complexity this is a
change to an existing analysis so I
don't think it's gonna
go way high I'm not I can't tell you how
much it's going to be but it's I think
it would be
well that's that's the average that's a
normal bill you know if something more
complicated you know would cost more
money um Senate Bill three to 11 years
ago cost a heck of a lot more than that
uh with its iterations but
um that's the range we're looking at so
so I both just spent twenty five hundred
dollars
500 a piece you know I believe every
roll call on the floor of the house is
five grand and we don't seem to ever
yeah the whole idea behind
representative Rogers at the time was we
kept asking for reviews and it was going
against the unfunded liability so
Marty and as soon as you obviously get
that to Melissa and Mr Hoffman and
and for those of you looking it's on
page 801 in the budget book
representative grassy we've got to get
you you could use represent a wireless
book because the page is not correct in
the documents you have there that's
oh well no it's I think that's
represented Wireless but
where's Mill's books it's in a locker in
all right if you could just introduce
yourself for us please good morning I'm
Susie anzalone Director of Finance for
the peas Development Authority
um so uh this is my first time in front
of this committee so I guess I will just
kind of give you a brief overview of the
budget itself and any questions so uh
the most important thing about
um the budget for the for the division
of ports and harbors is that we are
self-funded or pay as you go so
um the expenses in here have no impact
on the general fund or any other fund
there are some wages paid at the state
level and some benefits and then the PDA
reimburses monthly
so that's the the big picture of it
um pretty straightforward like I said
we've got uh we've got five full-time
positions here and just some benefits so
um you know not a lot of intricate stuff
in our budget other than salaries wages
and a few benefits
questions
yeah sure thank you
um did you have some open positions in
yes we did yes the uh Deputy Harbor
Master position was open for quite a
while and that's why some of those
expenses are smaller for that year yep
our our Harper Pilots part of your are
the employees our contractors or
they're the ones that run the tugboats
yeah they're contractors they're not
employees of the state except for we
have some Harbor Masters but they're not
the ones that run the tow boats am I
right
uh good morning my name is Wood Anderson
I'm the operations manager for the port
authority
um so Moran Towing is the tugboat
company that that is uh currently
contracted in the piscataqua river
um and then uh the Portsmouth Pilots
um are a separate entity but they fall
under the director of the poor its genos
rules and regulations
so that works
okay so but they're both contractors
they're not among these five correct
right correct okay I see and
so
how does someone well let me put it this
way I was once on the fiscal committee
and the pilots came to us and wanted an
increase in the rates are the rates that
we charge
um commercial ships to be piloted into
Portsmouth
yes those were actually ju yes those
were actually just amended I believe
in the last couple months I want to say
the last couple months last two or three
months those are just actually amended
those actually just went up
yeah
okay
um
all right well thank you
so several years ago maybe it's a decade
and a half ago you borrowed some money
from the state has that all been paid
back yes there's currently no debt owed
to the state at this time
okay
seeing done so Gino is still there
yes he is ah she's been there a long
time he's in the Bahamas right now oh
Jesus
I was hoping to see him he's always very
colorful he has some good stories about
it
fighting off lobsters and sharks and
stuff but
all right
um well thanks for so much for coming
over and answering our questions
anything
this is one of the easier budgets you'll
see yes that's why I was put on Friday
yeah
all right well seeing no further
questions again thank you and
you won't obviously need to come back
yeah
thank you very much so as a divisional
set of checking this off yeah
okay
that's still 47.
so Mr Anderson could I ask you a
question outside absolutely yeah just
um
yes that's represent
so we have section 45 which we have
discussed already the invest New
Hampshire 303 30 round that's 30 million
and then the affordable housing fund of
million section 47
the divisions
pleasure I I'm very uncomfortable with
two separate programs for one thing you
know uh duplicate it seems like
I don't know I did hear from a former
chairman umberger the other day and she
heard some of our discussion about the
matter she's probably watching right now
uh and she encouraged me to say that
some money
I don't know a specific amount but she
was very supportive of invest New
Hampshire for what they've done even in
her community as far as affordable
housing
as I said to her the other day all these
funds had been supported federally in
the past and these are all this is a
general fund asked for both
so it's 55 million dollars as a general
fund yeah so it's a lot of money
collectively and
I was go ahead represent so is invest
investment is not a loan right it's a
it's a grant yeah whereas the other one
is sort of alone but they they don't
collect very well is that I believe
eventually okay I believe you're good
but
yeah okay
um
are very little
negotiated interest yeah so yeah
it's basically it's a partnership
whereas the best I think you can get a
granted
oh everybody use their my experience
shadow
and she will sign them up
no because what they what the Senate
would do with this bill if they decide
to pass it is they would table it and
put it in their version of the budget
and then when we got to Committee of
conference we would work out the
differences okay so it's you can't have
bills that spend money in a budget year
and you know they have to be in the
budget so
and we would do the same thing if we had
such a bill
so what we've what we've done in the
past and those of you that have been on
division one or other divisions
knowing that the Senate has better
Revenue numbers and we do sometimes
we'll take something out knowing that
now they have Senate Bill 231 I believe
it is
um we could take these out entirely
or leave sometimes a dollar is just put
in as a placeholder but there's a lot of
options
represent Sweeney so I have just a
comment on invest NH and it's uh line 32
grants and Loans may be made by the
department to municipalities and two
housing developers I can understand
grants being made to municipalities and
I can understand loans being made to
developers but I'm confused about the
policy of Grants and Loans available to
both
municipalities and to the developers
almost like a separation of
if we're giving a grant to a
municipality for off-site or on-site
improvements for water or Road impacts
for development I get that and I
understand the financing and Loans to
the developers to allow them to build
the housing that they want uh I don't
think the state should be in the
business of giving grants to Developers
for construction or
I could see loans to municipalities for
their for any impacts of the projects
but I I without more I I just have a
question of how those grants to
developers would be used it invests in
age when we also have the affordable
housing financing for the developers to
access as well
yeah it was interesting to hear that
they can tap both resources and then
afford the affordable housing fund comes
in at the end and reassesses based on
what their needs are if they're getting
the other funds from invest in h and to
stretch the dollar it just seems that
if we maybe identify them more in their
Lanes like invest in H's to Grants to
municipalities
for the impact of housing projects and
that affordable housing fund is to the
developers to loan the financing that
might make it clearer and not have so
much overlap I think what you're looking
at I think what you're looking at here
though is some of those grants that are
going out are not just going to
municipalities but they're going to
non-profits like housing Partnerships
and housing authorities which
technically are not the government so
that's one of the questions you take a
look at there that the non-profits deal
in both grants and Loans so that maybe
I'm making an assumption here but I
think it may be what what they're
talking about and I think I think if we
have those NG the non-government
organizations that aren't the housing
Developers
we incorporate that into the language
here in hb2 it just says housing
developers yeah and that's that's
everyone probably well you know
depending on what it is it may be it
appropriate to have a grant but I I
certainly I don't disagree with you yeah
and it's something we may want to
clarify sure I just think if they come
and they say oh we already have those
guidelines in place in the card rails so
we're not granting to a billion dollar
housing developer right to build you
know 50 units but so yeah no I I agree
yeah
representative McGuire yeah to to me
this is a program started by the federal
government and now
being shifted onto us you know what I
it just seems like if we keep these
things going we're going to we're going
to be asked for this kind of money again
and again and again
um I think we will be anyway well we
would believe anyway sure well I thought
it was interesting I think it was a
response to your question digging into
the document representative McGuire that
since they were established in 1988
they've been allocated 62 million
dollars
and at the most they said they could do
about a thousand units per year right
now they have five hundred thousand
dollars in their fund
so it did seem like a
a lot of money the 25 million at least
in that line I thought I'd dig down into
it but I thought I heard them say the
previous budget had 25 million also is
that right of General funds yes
yeah so this is just the same as last
budget
oh I miss that so of the 62 million
you know
30 37 was the past 40 years and then 25
was last time you know something like
that right so it's
this I guess was always Federal right
and not state or for the most part for a
long period of time
and I'm not familiar with what they
receive for federal funds because we
only see the general fund piece but
there is also in the real estate
transfer tax an allocation of 5 million
a year that goes to the affordable
so that comes off the top of the real
estate transfer tax
because certainly if the Senate could
bring it back and they'll have better
revenues which might be better it might
so the pleasure represent I mean I don't
mind I don't mind moving that we
eliminate these two sections I mean
I I just don't care for this kind of
all right so are you moving that yeah
so is it seconded no I'll send it in for
all right which section do you like
better
that's the appropriation of 25 million
the affordable housing fund right okay
so why is that one because it's a loan
well I thought the Senate Bill had both
it has both plus 15 million for
something else I thought well let's look
at it
not that it really shouldn't matter
yeah yeah it does that's accurate okay
it has
so if you look at the fiscal notes at
eight million dollars to the Department
of Health and Human Services for shelter
programs two million
or housing stabilization 25 million for
the which we're discussing now Housing
Finance Authority and 30 million for the
business and economic affairs
affordable Workforce housing yeah so it
you're happy
that's a house anybody else any
I see a lot of conversation over there
any thoughts
there's also a section
um with that historic housing
preservation credit that's in House Bill
2 who's also in this Senate bill
oh that's an incentive Bill too
the uh in best New Hampshire
refers to RSA 6 7458 which is Workforce
housing
it limits the grants to uh affordable
how
for sale housing which is tenants for
sale
which is Affordable to a household
income of no more than 100 percent of
the median income for a poor person
household for the metropolitan area
and it also
limits income up to 60 percent of the
so there's limit on the type of projects
that's already an existing statute
Mr Hoffman you showed me a document this
morning earlier about how we stood as
far as a division on our
bottom line
or house bill one yeah a million dollars
under where the governor was for the
biennium
most of that would be attributable to
the judicial branch reductions that was
almost 2 million
then there was some general fund
ads with the Department of Revenue
so right around a little bit over a
million dollars below what the governor
and what about two
I'll spill two I'll spill two there are
a lot of balls in the air I don't think
any of the
the large decisions have been made in
hospital too there was a section
approved for Corrections I.T that's
so just for the division on Monday Mr
Hoffman will give us a and Melissa a
breakdown of where we are and everything
that we've done will be grayed out be
like highlighted gray and the things
that haven't been accomplished will
still be white and black
well we do have to come up with some
Cuts I again we still have a weaker week
and a half we do have a session day next
week we have a full committee day next
week so
we could I suppose wait till Monday is
that work for everybody and make some
hard decisions Monday right I mean I
have
yeah I haven't seen
that I a budget for us in the sense that
division one take all your bills take
House Bill one take House Bill two and
and make it add up to X right you know I
haven't gotten there yet that's you know
so I mean I think our chairman needs to
give us our part of the job right he's
working on it okay so maybe we should
wait on the big stuff like this until we
see that yeah because
the revenues that we saw I think
yesterday was about 130 million off the
governors yes proposal well if we looked
at the Surplus we have we wouldn't have
to cut anything if we wanted to go into
the Surplus well I thought the Surplus
no I don't think this they put in the
revenue it may be raw but
because of our Surplus and again we
don't know what we're going to get back
from the Departments it hasn't been
spent so we're still in a pretty good
spot but we don't we can't really add
anything but we should be subtracting
and whether H.R 17 has
right so it is I think the Surplus is
no there's no apps because it's still a
everybody anticipates good lapses but we
don't know I mean there won't be any
well because the governor's he's got a
surplus statement of Mr Hoffman and
what what's the Surplus Mike is it like
after everything was bent and
I'm sorry almost 150 so it's a little
off yeah so
so oh I see yeah so it's not in there so
you're saying if we did nothing we just
simply wouldn't add to the rainy day
right
yes well if we stuck with the governor's
plan entirely but his Revenue numbers
are
are higher by a 130 million
but what about all our hospitals
well those haven't been figured in yet
right
oh yeah oh because the way I always
thought no
what I hadn't heard from from you guys
is
the house bills
plus House Bill one plus House Bill 2
minus HR
17.
um and not changing the rainy day fund
there's about 130 million sure is that
that sounds about right but I think Mr
Keynes that's what I heard from Mr
Speaker his suggestion was that it um if
there's something you want to do in a
bill
finding a Mountain House Bill too that
you don't want to do
to stay within the
in the range
all right so so if we cut to what say is
an easy example if we cut 25 million
from the housing that would give us
a lot of money to fund all these house
bills that we're working on which don't
add up to it except for
571 which is 84 million
all right
but but I thought when I asked Mr Kane
the question I said add the house bills
add House Bill one add House Bill 2
subtract H.R 17.
so don't change the rainy day fund and
what's left and he said to me so you
okay
yeah we'll have all the sheets it'll
make a lot more sense once we have the
spreadsheets that they're working on
what we've done all the Departments
there's always if we just focus on
each day but if you start looking at the
full picture it gets very common well
yeah I mean personally I would like I
like making cuts from policy so we can
have the communications tax cut so we
can put more in the rainy day fund stuff
like that I thought you didn't like the
rainy day fund
well if there was more there
then we can yeah all right escort
less asking all right let's ask but
you're right I mean
yeah because if we go forward and cut
the communications tax and you're losing
what 28 million dollars a year that's
right which but that's in the governor's
bud that's in his budget but it doesn't
mean we have to accept that as as Ways
and Means hasn't accepted it
yeah
but it's your housing money so well so
this is a question for representative
Sweeney perhaps but
um I somebody made the comment to me if
you don't have any tax cuts that's a
hundred Republican votes for the budget
that go away
and so baby that you know well we're all
walking
yeah okay because we're walking a very
tight rope obviously we have you folks
had a good day yesterday I
representative Sweeney up quite a few
but we have so many competing interests
to be fair on both sides and I'm sure
when the budget comes up for about
people will be wheeled in wheelchairs
for that day but but I think that's why
the governor put in the communication
tax it's the smallest one right so well
it's but the easiest to collect you know
we heard that oh yeah there's only a
half a person that collects 28 million
we didn't did we ask the question what's
the hardest text to collect I don't know
as he explained it the half person it's
it's it is complex they go into the
insurance things and have to determine
the difference between texts and data
right well
and you can see it on the on in HR 7
. so in hr7 the number for 2023 was
39 million
but after they've they have a better
look at it it's down to 29 million
right so two years ago they thought the
communication tax was a was a 10 million
dollar better than it actually is
right so there's another reason to get
would you like to join us why sure okay
only hurts for a little while
whatever
okay
sorry
all right we'll open the work session
where the New Hampshire Commission on
Aging and I'm not sure where in the
page 131 131 what's on the index on the
right hand side no I couldn't I was I
skipped over I guess
all right if you could just state your
name for the record please and if your
last name is difficult Please spell it
for our Clerk
[Laughter]
hello my name is Rebecca Skye s-k-y oh
that's easy there you go
um thank you members of the committee
for for hearing from the state
Commission on Aging
um
are we ready I'll just start because
this start is just an introduction to
the Commission on Aging the Commission
on Aging is a real is is a relatively
new organization within the state
government it was established during the
2019 legislative session
um RSA chapter 19 P with a primary
charge of advising the governor and the
general court on issues related to aging
um who is the commission
um the commission consists of 26 very
smart very committee committed members
of the legislature state agencies
um Governor appointees supported by 1.57
FTE currently
the full list of the commission members
is on the left side of the front page of
the February issue of our newsletter
that I've provided with you today it's
one of the things behind the paper clip
the newsletter aging matters is produced
by a commission member and is published
monthly you each receive it in your
legislature email address
it's chocked full of information some
articles focused on policy issues but
the majority valuable information you
can share with your constituents please
let us know if you'd like to receive it
at an alternative address or if you have
content that you'd like to have included
this newsletter is just one item product
that we provide to the public
the commission meets monthly doing so
even during the early days of covid the
commission also has four task force and
one subcommittee that also each heat
monthly
the committee assesses existing and
potential public policies Effectiveness
in providing an opportunity for all of
us as we age to be a thriving part of
the fabric of the communities in which
we live
during the past legislative session we
tracked over 60 bills in the state
legislature providing written
information education to legislators on
over 10 bills the current section
session we are tracking 36 bills to date
and have provided written information
and education on 13 bills so far just
this am I facilitated a session that was
requested by Senators Bradley and
Whitley after the um
on Senate Bill 36 they asked that the
DHHS meet with Advocates to discuss
Senate Bill 36 assistance of care for
healthy aging Bill and that was a
meeting that I helped facilitate this
morning
um
very challenging meeting they would like
a an amendment to bring to the floor of
the Senate by Wednesday so
um we also investigate investigate
current issues and respond to concerns
raised by various stakeholders including
the public at large to hear those
concerns we conduct Community engagement
sessions throughout the state throughout
the year this past year hearing from
community members about the devastating
impact of covet upon senior centers in
senior programming we worked with the
governor's office and Bea to find ways
to bring Federal relief funds to the
senior centers
um
we Implement an annual Awards program
honoring older adult volunteers across
the state which has been a tradition in
the state since 1962.
we publish that actual annual Awards
program at this point we have one you
have one more week left to submit a
nomination for somebody who lives in
your community it's a great opportunity
we have a ceremony in the executive
Chambers the governor of the state has
participated in this award ceremony
since 1962. it's a great way to to honor
the people who live in your community
um we publish an annual report each
November 1st a copy of the executive
summary is also attached to this
testimony
um
and that should give you a sense of the
breadth and depth of the of the work
that the commission
um does the commission you know why was
the commission created um if you flip to
the back side of that executive summary
um you'll see a graph um that that shows
the demographics of our state and how
they're changing our mean age is rising
currently one-third of New Hampshire's
population is over age 55.
the 80 plus population is is currently
at 4.3 percent of our population
Bea's population projections published
in September suggest that by the year
2050 close to 12 percent of our state's
population will be 80 and older
this fries is said to have a significant
impact Upon Our State how are
communities function how and on our
County and state budgets
the commission is here to study the
related issues and inform and educate
the governor and general court on how to
how we can shape our policies systems
and communities in response to these
changes and to maintain and even improve
upon the quality of life here in New
Hampshire
so um just as I'm sure you're interested
in the numbers so to shift it to a
discussion of the Commission on Aging
budget
um I just have four bullet points one
where we are a small But Mighty agency
with a 1.57 staff with very basic office
operations uh you can see that the the
everything I provided to use prevent uh
printed in black and white that's about
what I have funding for
um 83 um percent of the of the fiscal
year 24 budget before you and 84 of the
fiscal year 25 budget is for salary and
benefits
uh there is a staffing increase in the
fiscal year 2425 budget for a 0.4 FTE or
15 hours a week person
um these hours will be utilized for
administrative support and policy
analysis to improve the the quality the
quantity and quality of services
outlined in RSA 19p.2 and align with the
commission goals that are in the budget
documents one through four uh funding
will allow me more to uh this one will
allow me to more focus on the role of an
executive director writing Grant
proposals to bring additional resources
to the state
creating the desired impact of
commission the Department's operating
budget increases over from fiscal year
to fiscal year I mean fiscal year 23 to
fiscal year 24 beyond the Staffing to
incorporate a planning consultant for
strategic planning that we hope
um you will engage in we hope to do this
over the this coming summer when the
commission first met we did a quick
strategic map of of what areas to
investigate and at this point we're
ready to Embark Upon A a master plan or
a multi-sectoral plan on Aging it's a
long year a long-term 10-year plan to
think about what our state needs to do
to address this demographic ship we hope
to engage policy leaders we hope to
engage other state leaders across the
state on over this coming summer
um and then the only other shifts to the
budget really are are because we're a
relatively new agency and we're still
establishing the ground rules for what
our budget is
um there's a new interagency transferred
to doit in class 27 that was added in
this biennium budget there's a fiscal
year 24 transfers to other agencies like
General Services has increased
significantly since prior budgets and
I'm happy to answer any questions you
might have
I know representative McGuire has a
question he said we should approve your
budget if you can stop his aging process
[Laughter]
when I was in my 20s I thought by now
there would be no hair on my head but
because it was essentially the same
amount it was a slightly different color
but it was a similar amount anyway
um so what's the difference between the
commission and citizen commissioners
so the members of the commission are
um there's two Representatives
um McKay and McMahon there's one Senator
who's uh is uh centered again in this
year there are eight state agency reps
as outlined in the RSA
um so there's from from various state
agencies
um and then we have the remaining 13
members of the commission are appointed
by the governor and their mix of uh
regular people in the community who are
aging like all of us as well as people
who work in the field of Aging Services
so so you have people who are
specialists in geriatrics
um I do not believe we have a physician
currently on that commission but they're
they're spent when I say from the field
there are people who um work in the
Meals on Wheels programs who work at the
cap programs
um who else do we have uh
um I should look at my own list
um
uh we have somebody from who works at uh
who's uh who's a population Health
person
um from a hospital that's our chair Sue
Ruka she's a pretty impressive person
has done a lot of amazing work up in the
North Conway area
um
um those types of folks okay so yeah I
mean do you think you should have like
required a physician of some kind
um
I don't think it that would be a bad
choice I think that it could enhance the
commission
um to have somebody with that that
Health background because
we all want to age healthy that's for
sure and the other piece of it is is you
know there's so much to be done to ready
our our communities uh there's a
movement
um for how
um age-friendly Health Systems it you
would look at who goes to our hospitals
and you would think that of course that
you know they would be geared up like
any other organization to
um uh cater to older adults but that's
you know they're big bureaucracies and
they aren't and they have to do special
initiatives uh to change the way that
they do the business to really best
serve older adults I mean we've all been
in there we've all seen that so having
somebody from that Healthcare
perspective would help us address that a
bit more we at one point did have the
CEO from Cross County Family Medicine
who was on the commission
um we just his time was time to turn the
any further questions
I just have one quick question so all
these appointed citizen Commissioners
none of them are compensated for
anything not nothing whatsoever they
don't even get travel
at their level of commitment is just
amazing they every single one of them is
very engaged in this work and works very
hard at their task
ing representative cambrell's or numbers
me and over there nothing okay
all right seeing no further questions
thank you very much we'll I guess check
this box and you'll be all set thank you
so now what I thought we might be able
to do is uh go back into perhaps hb2 is
that all right with you representative
McGuire it's fine with me
um we got an hour right yeah we got an
hour
so hopefully we uh things are a little
clearer than mud here but one of the
things we
heard its session yesterday is that Ways
and Means came out with their revenue
estimates and
they did not act on the governor's
Communications tax proposal that cut 28
million and 24 and roughly 28 million
actually it's 28.9 but
uh in 25
the LBA has been working as those cuts
have actually occurred
I just learned that this morning so they
they've kind of been using that as a
number
going for it so it's about 56 million
dollars I know representative
McGuire would probably like to move to
support removing
yeah the sections dealing with the
communications tax
so yeah so this is sections 102 through
110.
we have two seconds
foreign
so
could you clear look clerk has a
question
representative so
I guess my question would be should we
should we take action on this before we
assess the other moving parts that we're
I don't know
I mean we could or
um
representative McGuire would you like to
speak to your motion
yeah
um so I think
some tax cut and this is kind of the the
minimum I mean just to speak from a
political point of view some tax cut is
going to be important to get a lot get a
good chunk of votes for the budget and
this is this is sort of the minimum
possible
um I would think
um all the other numbers on this budget
page are much larger than this one
um it's so and it's something that the
governor has already approved so
therefore it's already in the bottom
line
um it's not in it's not in ways and
means it's bottom line because they
uh they just operate off of current law
so that's why they put the number in but
they themselves have a bill that does
exactly this that they retained so they
kind of dumped it in our lap
so I think we should do it
representative Griffin
to add to that
we get testimony the other day on the
difficulty
collecting this tax a lot of it
goes to large corporations and
they have to sort out
what's data
what's uh data from
you know other transfers Within
what's phone and
and covered by the tax versus data
transfers and video transfers
that
are so typical of the internet today and
it's likely only going to get more
complex so
given the difficulty of
broadening these
companies and coming up with realistic
numbers on whatso
I think we could put the uh
free up to half a man that does this and
have them do more productive things in
Revenue
thank you representative Griffin further
represents Sweeney famous chairman just
following up on representative Griffin's
comments uh projections for the return
on this tax are just diminishing across
the board and as more and more phone
calls are made using data and not
sell not actual phone service the
ability for us to collect this tax under
federal guidelines diminishes even
further
um so I I would support the repeal I
think it's a it's a smart move for us to
do this now so that we can then have the
clear picture of what we have to budget
with
seeing no further questions that like
I don't know if that would satisfy the
situation because it would save 30
representative Griffin followed by well
the testimony the other day
uh basically said that they'll be
continued Revenue even if we just
continue the tax because
the audits on uh previous years on these
larger companies will continue for a
period of years
so it's not like
it won't produce any Revenue which is
represent grass yeah one of the concerns
that I have is that you know you talk
about we want to eliminate attacks but
then we have to find an expenditure
that's equal to that amount that to
eliminate as well and I know one of the
discussions we have this morning was to
eliminate housing funds and I'm opposed
to the elimination of the housing funds
and so I would be opposed to the
elimination of this this tax unless you
can tell me someplace else you want to
take this money from
um you know I think you you eliminate
something something's got to be cut and
when we've got priorities such as
housing in New Hampshire I don't think
this is the place to go at least not at
all right seeing no further questions so
to be clear this is a repeal the
communications tax starting its section
is that correct representative McGuire
Maria when the clerk is ready please
call the roll okay I just want to
this is a motion to repeal the
communications tax that is in sections
101 to 110. representative McGuire moved
and Sweeney seconded yeah is that right
it would be basically supporting what's
in House Bill 2 in those sections okay
supporting it okay sorry that's why I
reiterate
hb2 okay
uh
uh uh representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells yes
representative Hewitt yes
the clerk votes no representative
leishman yes
okay so the final vote is one two three
four five six six to two and uh the
for other suggestions representative
McGuire
um how about have we taken care of the
parking garage
we have not
we have the one we have to take the 15
out because we have the separate bill Mr
Hoffman we have an amendment to delete
the parking garage from House Bill 2
with the thought that the bill would
proceed quickly through the process
okay so has someone voted House Bill 384
ought to pass or yeah we did remember
you were the Lone Wolf oh so so it's all
done then yeah yeah it's going it's on
the agenda for next week
departure pass amended right and so has
the section of House Bill 2 been
removed
yes we have an amendment to delete those
two sections
and we approve that amount yes oh so
it's all done okay
yeah that's it I think
yeah all right that was part of the
overall
yeah so there'll be an amendment that
will be forthcoming next week Monday or
whatever for the elimination of the 15
million dollars that was in house bill
2.
okay we'll have a packet with all the
house bill two amendments
now any other sections of House Bill 2
that you would
oh I can discuss or anybody else on the
division are there any Granite place
all right well I'm looking at this paper
it's the wrong paper but anyway yeah
it's uh so rep for representative grassy
we have a sheet here you'll get good
quick learning questions
still overwhelmed well we don't have
enough to get all shuffled in that's
true we're still all learning too
Granite places section 75 page 31.
right so it's
75 and 76.
um
so I guess assuming that the parking
garage is a done deal then this is kind
of a done deal too it's a
that's my I guess you're good to see
that
so we might as well approve but thank
you
all right so I had a thought on this I
to take a look at it from the arpa
standpoint
I don't know if that's worth it or not
if we don't
we can ask the commissioner if our
performance would be available for that
purchase
is that the yeah please
just follow up so I mean the way that um
the way that the youth the YDC is
written it says if there's federal funds
available they could first be used arpa
funds and then General funds so I don't
know if we would want to consider doing
does that make sense
I mean if we could get the arpa funds
I don't know if you guys heard what I
just said so all right they're available
right
but I just the way he talked on Friday I
don't know how fast they would put it
through the process but we could ask and
if he thinks it's going to take a while
we could just write it the way they did
for you I just see
it
I mean the other thing was the other
thing was that the last time we put
money into affordable housing it was our
performance
so uh probably the best thing to do
would be starting on page one of the
by pages
I think we've already done
yeah starting from the top I suppose
you're easier
so we've already done one and two and Mr
Hoffman and Melissa correct me if I'm
wrong
um
we have the Liquor Commission funds for
incentive
yes it sounds like we did something
about that right now that was accepted
all the way
the entire first page has been accepted
what about the PCB assistance down
third section 38. that's on page
yeah representative evil had something
um
so one that's well so these are
conflating a couple of issues but um I
did do you remember I talked to the
director about maybe being you being
able to use part of the PCB 6 million
for pfas but he
um
he said that that was really a decision
to be made by the Water Division so I
haven't really pursued that but
the other thing that I talked to him
about is that remember I don't know if
you all read the letter that came from
from wimsat that sort of uh spelled out
the money that was in the pfas funds did
you print that out for them you may not
have yeah
I mean I think we should see that but
another comp because there was a bill
that wanted to appropriate another it
was HB 212 a one to appropriate another
two million dollars
for pfas investigation so I talked to
the director and they may be able to
expand the use of the existing funds for
that
all of which is to say that the I think
they prefer to leave the PCB 6 million
intact
all right so you'll get something to us
on that so I'm going to work on
Amendment with Des on the on the pfas
issue
I was tasked with speaking to
representative renzullo about this
section
um the you know the chair of the
resources department
and
um he thought he didn't like the the the
the way this is written he thought it
was too too vague too general you know
similar complaint that we had on that
that other thing about the
broad rule making and so he would have
much rather see it as a bill
and come before his committee and they
can put in limits and and more specifics
so
um
he thought we could safely uh eliminate
this section
but that section is it's
38 7 38 39.
um
but if I I speaking at lunch the
representative grassy has a different
represent grassy yeah I mean I mean one
of the things is that there were two
ways of looking at the pfas money I mean
whether they could fit it into some of
their existing programs or not I'm not
sure but uh certainly uh Des when
they're doing this they get standards
down from the EPA and when you know I
don't think the committee needs to see
this in fact actually there's been
discussion in the past that it's
probably not you know they don't want
the committee to set the standards
because Des sets their own standards on
these things but they need the funding
to do the initial investigations and to
the scientific research to get this
stuff done so I would I would support
some funding being left in the in the
program not necessarily all of the
funding but I and and I think that what
representative Ebel has said is that
she's working with particularly Mike
winstat we may be able to get a better
indication the first of the week on this
if we can get uh some information back
on from them
all right we'll hold on that for a
couple of days and then moving to page
to the top of two we have section 40.
and we heard a little about that with
commissioner Caswell I believe the
office of regulatory review would be a
new
Department I think something that caught
my eye on the
section 41 was the appropriation of 750
000 is per year yeah per year and I
don't think there was any plan of number
employees or I think it represented yeah
I think I think it was seven if I
remember right
um I spoke to Carol about this one
because it's about rule making right and
it's about
getting people to
review rules from the point of view of
business I guess and um and comment on
them and stuff like that but
um
personally I I think we should eliminate
this section 40 and 41.
because to me it's like
we we have we hire people to make room
to write rules so they and we have a
legislative committee that very
carefully reads through rules and makes
sure that they comport with law
um but
but this is hiring new people
to
um to complain about rules you know what
I mean it's like it's like we hire
people to do a job and then we hire some
other people to complain about the job I
mean it's like you know no disrespect to
representative you are but it's like
that old joke you know one low air in
town starves and two of them uh you know
live very well you know so I I just
don't think it makes sense
so representative McGuire is supporting
when you
remove this section take it out yes I
mean it's not a big it's not a big
amount of money I think it's a million
and a half yeah I agree with that I
think this is just more growth of
government we don't need it
okay it's unanimous we don't need to
take a vote again okay wait the clerk
needs to get this note taken okay wait
sucks there's a lot of things going on
so Melissa yeah
40 and 41. so we pick up 750 000 a year
excuse me
so the new subdivision next 42 historic
housing preservation tax credit
it's not
okay
so this is a new Senate 231 the bill
with the other money that's correct oh
okay
so the wishes of the division
let me read this so this is uh it's 18
and 19.
I'm trying to remember if we had anyone
speak to this that's coming I don't
Mr chair
I have a note next to this one
um
possible referral to Ways and Means with
a question mark
I think one of the members suggested
maybe they'd want to look at that tax
credit yeah all right representative
Maguire had suggested
all right well
I understand McGuire
yeah so this is
this is something like the
the interest in dividends tax credit I
think right you what this is is
um a tax credit
against I'm not even sure which tax oh
there's a list of taxes so this is
probably b-e-t BPT and interest in
dividends is that what it is it's uh
b-e-tbt and insurance premium tax
insurance premium tax so this this
language was mirrored after the cdfa
tax credit language
and that one includes the insurance
premium taxes in there during Senate
Finance they were asking that question
why
with insurance premium tax included
because they didn't know how that would
factor into receiving credit on taxes if
insurance companies were going to donate
to get donate to this historic housing
tax try to make a contribution and then
get a credit against their tax and there
really wasn't an answer for it except
that it was mirrored after cdfa
and what is CDF I'm sorry Community
Development Finance Authority
tax credit
yeah I'm
yes
ship it over to wasted means please
maybe get a read on it yeah that's right
this is I was supposed to call them
yes yeah and I didn't do it yeah okay so
ask Gloria well thank you
they'd be happy to take it over there
all right so that would take us down
then to appropriation for invest New
Hampshire
yes represents on the invest New
Hampshire and the affordable housing
fund I I'll kind of sign up for to talk
to the special committee on housing
about their views on it and I think
there has been conversations about
having two offices administer funds that
can go sorted to the same area but not
exactly
um
I mean there's there's works there's
ways to work here to
I don't know to me speaking for myself
having one office focused on invest in
age where it's just housing across the
board funding and then the affordable
housing which is for the actual
affordable housing units
where invest in age can go to large
developers who aren't affordable I kind
of want to iron all those issues out and
talk with the special Committee just to
get their taste on things before we make
any recommendations
all right so we have representative
Sweeney looking at sections 43 through
48.
Mr chair I was just going to add in here
that in the past we saw the affordable
housing money that went to the Housing
Authority come through the capital
right you know I think it's something I
think it's a good point representative
what you're talking about here is why do
we have two departments administering
similar amounts of monies if we could
get both of those pools of money you
know put a divider line between the two
pools put them in the same Department
you know at New Hampshire housing would
probably be a far better location to
have them than to have two
administrations differing up separately
I think that's that's a great idea thank
you yeah to that point exactly because
it sounds like New Hampshire housing is
working with developers on their
projects they put together they open the
initial plan and then they can go and
get money from invest in h and then
housing uses their funds separately and
I think getting it Under One Roof and
having it have the ability to make the
full plan at once will reduce staff time
and allow them to have more reach for
the dollar and and in actuality you know
governmental agencies and ngos have
always worked with New Hampshire housing
as well right and maybe it's you know if
they've got three three staff people one
place you move one staff person over and
you've solved all the problems yeah
all right thank you representative
grassy and Sweeney for that
now we've already we jumped just
uh Bridges house we've acted on that
both 66 and 67 but the next
section 68 representative McGuire You
chair the discussion when Corrections
was here so yeah
so this is a tough one because this is
one of our biggest this if we need a cut
I mean this is the biggest one and it's
fairly easy in the sense that
um you know it's it's 40 million dollars
or 50 million dollars I guess
um
they made a pretty reasonable case I
mean we gave we essentially gave
Corrections everything they wanted
um but they made a fairly reasonable
case that the prisons wearing out right
and and
um at some point we've got to build a
new one
but it but it is a you know it the
question is how urgent is it right I
mean it's uh
so prisons been here for eight since 18
something or other it's going to be here
for the next however many years but
I don't know
representative evil
sorry if I keep talking about public
works but it is a cap project I mean one
of the ways that we used to handle these
things is that um we would give them
some money to get the design and
Engineering going without
and then once they had done their design
and Engineering they would come in and
then they would make the ask of course
in this case the ask would probably be
300 million dollars but you could give
them
something to get going or we could also
I can go back to Public Works and and
and talk to them about it but um
to give them nothing would also be
challenging if they just want to start
to do some design work
further comments on that it would seem
to me anyway at least to give them the
10 million dollars for site design
location and then maybe take the 40 out
for Nano
I mean where you were going
representative that's sort of what I
thought but I I'm also happy to talk to
um chair McConkey about it or we can
we'll try to make a decision yeah
they've they've decided that it has to
be in Concord
um we asked about more more space in
Berlin Etc
um
but yeah I guess the the design is
important
um and but the 10 million I think is not
enough even to finish the design right
it's it's well Mr Hanson said that they
usually base those things on square
footage and he thought it might be more
like 25 million but of course 25 is also
a hunk
that's so
I mean we could go back and ask him
I mean they they denied that I've heard
from many sources that the women's
prison recently constructed was not done
as an efficient design right that that
it has more officers per per uh inmate
than than the others and so I think
there's they found there's more places
to hide in there yes something like that
so
um hopefully they won't make that
mistake again with this one but I don't
know how to specify it you know what I
mean
unless you just trust them to learn from
things they learned from their previous
experience
well we could put
10 million dollars into 24 and again
this will be going to the Senate maybe
we can get more information and take the
40 out all together
might be okay you'll be okay not okay
okay so we'll keep section 40 and remove
section 41.
71.
right 72 or 72.
so I think we probably if we do that
we'd have to move 70 of men 70 to put in
24.
it's yeah it's really
so Melissa and Mr Hoffman is a weird
again moving the 10 million to 24
and taking out the 40 and 24 all
together why not leave it in 23.
I think in general we have more 23
dollars than we have
others
that's all right
that's fine we could do that too Mr
you've had the same messaging that if we
can put it in 23 to put it in 23 because
there are currently more funds in 23. so
we can leave it there I think that's
probably yeah we'll do that could you
sort of restate where we are and I'll
write it down so we're keeping keeping
sections 68 69 and 70 and removing
section 72.
I'm sorry 68 through 71.
why doesn't 72 have an effective date
I'm not sure it's uh well it says fiscal
year ending in
June 30th 2024.
so that's where yes your Note is
oh maybe because 23 if you have money in
23 you need an effective date because
you're
allocating things otherwise not
appropriate yeah right when the uh Draft
House Bill 2 now they'll uh
anything that doesn't have an effective
date will default to July 1st 2023.
okay all right so that's
why
yeah you could be saying we'll we'll
have a show of hands okay so
um in hb2 under the corrections section
we're going to keep section 68 to 71.
which is 10 million dollars
and then remove section 72 which is 40
million
all right sound good to everyone
in favor
represent grassy okay with this or
kids unanimous thanks the only thing I'd
say here is that for the 10 million it
says designing and constructing should
we just say designing or just leave it
yes that sounds like a good idea yeah
because it
was designing
so Melissa and Mike just a short
amendment to see
so representative McGuire again the
correction step below that you were here
for that the I.T infrastructure and yes
we I think we approved essentially all
of that stuff didn't we
oh yeah holding on granite
place so representative evil can ask
about arpa or somebody can ask about
Barbara funds
Melissa and Mike could you ask
so that's
so we're all set on that people listen
yes
so I want to wait for 83
that's a Christa McAuliffe Memorial it
was like what 500
ID on this is a lot of times for these
things they take charitable donations
too I don't know what the total amount
is for the
if they really think five well we can
wait until she
any
well it appropriates five hundred
thousand
right it allows donations but it
appropriates yeah but it's out of the
blocks and it appropriates 500 000. it's
also for the state house right
yeah Mr Hoffman and Melissa do we have a
new date for the commissioner to come in
you know
excuse me nothing I'm aware of I can run
across and check with Janet
oh we can I hope she'll be in next week
but we could probably save this for them
but it does appear to be something that
we ought to take a close look at
representative Sweeney
do we know in the past what was the
funding for Daniel Webster Franklin
Pierce General Stark who funded those
taxes if anyone knows you would know
that I don't but I could ask and I can
tell you who funded the Lincoln picture
in these in the main hall
so uh I mean in reps Hall yeah okay so
the Lincoln picture is the newest one of
the five okay
and
um it was funded by school children
so what happened was we have fourth
graders come to this visit
and so like in the 20s
um the fourth graders came and they
looked at the pictures in reps Hall and
they said you don't have Lincoln he's
the most important one you know
so so they started a program called
pennies for the portrait
and school children all over the state
donated pennies and they raised fifteen
hundred dollars and that was used to
paint the portrait of Lincoln wow and so
that's a gift from the school children
of New Hampshire to the legislature
so yeah so sometimes money is raised
you can ask all the questions you want
yeah
that was very interesting yeah one
parallel thing is the um the monument is
it the to the state police out for the
lob I'm not sure we funded that I think
that might have been contributions I'm
not sure yeah right out here to the left
yeah I'm not sure but well we'll see the
commissioner hopefully in the next week
and get some answers to that
representative McGuire's yeah I mean we
could sort of informally have a policy
that whatever the estimate is we'll pay
half or something like that you know do
that might be kind of open-ended if we
you know well no I mean get an estimate
and they they say this a statue costs
yeah a million therefore 500 yeah I'm
not sure why it's dncr doing this for
a steakhouse
I don't recall was just supposed to be
on the State House grounds on State
House grounds
it might be the cultural resource part
of dncr as opposed to the parks and
stuff
this is a cultural thing right so well I
was just wondering because it's a state
house I mean it's artistic and I thought
all right well we'll see the
commissioner hopefully next week and
get some questions answered there
so that we can skip down over 97 that's
we did Board of tax and land Appeals
uh did we do the state line you know
so we did all the tax for the
communication yeah section 115
um I asked the question this is the
second second injuries special fund well
that's right okay so I spoke to will
infantine the labor committee about this
and he gave me the history which is that
this is a program added in World War II
following World War II because
um the the idea was
if you if somebody who had previously
had some kind of injury later gets
injured on the job and it maybe
aggravates their original injury there's
some money here to reimburse the the
um workman's comp for those second
injuries right so
um and the idea was it it would make it
easier to hire veterans of World War II
because some many of them had trapnel or
other kinds of injuries and so this this
therefore
employers might be reluctant to hire
them and and so that was the purpose of
this fund and
um
and so over the years it's been
it's it's sort of had a similar effect
in the sense that maybe somebody gets
injured on job number one and then later
they they try to take job number two and
and again because of the second injury
feature
it makes employer number two more likely
to hire them right because somebody who
has a history of an injury might be more
more you know uh likely to get injured a
second time or something like that but
he's anyways he told me he was going to
put out some feelers among people in in
insurance and and to see whether
how important the second fund is to them
still right it could be sort of obsolete
so
that's a long way of saying we don't
know yet
I'm putting McGuire researching yeah
right
I thought I would listen to them and
agreed with them they were going to get
uh I have a note here that
representative Schultz was going to look
into it
because she was sitting there and uh
yeah
all right well maybe you represent
Maguire you want another task well yeah
I'm already waiting to hear back from I
mean it's not only just people injured
during World War II but you also I mean
they're mostly gone now but the ones
that were injured in Desert Storm yeah I
mean is does it still have any that
validity to that yeah it's it's it's
again it's it's for any second injury
right it's it's it's a kind of an
insurance among all
um workman's comp carriers that that
covers second injuries that possibly
could be related to it to an earlier
injury so
as opposed to
just a a plain injury that causes you
know something that has to be fixed
it could be an injury that aggravates
you know some anyway representative
Griffin has something I I don't know I
I'm pretty sure when they testified they
they said that Most states were getting
rid of
rid of these sons that they were kind of
obsolete
well I'm sure the folks from
that have been sitting here probably
don't want to listen to us any further
so you're welcome to come forward this
is a work session on Military Affairs
and Veterans Services and I think there
was a house bill that we had a question
for you upon as well but let's see if I
can find that
but in the meantime I guess you have a
handout
let's see 3 30 yes National Guard
recruiting incentive program
so for the record Mr chair my name is
Warren Perry I'm the deputy agent
general for New Hampshire's Department
of military Affairs and veteran services
and with me is Miss Judy Chen she is the
administrator of Finance for the
Department
we're happy to be here and happy to
testify and ready to do you want to
start with that question Mr chair or do
you want me to go ahead and give myself
sure if you wanted for those looking for
what page it's 199 in the budget book
so House Bill 330 is has three or three
or four components one is it increases
the amount of us of a uh incentive
payment to members who of current
members of the New Hampshire National
Guard up to the grade of Captain
and former members of the New Hampshire
National Guard if they refer somebody
who ships to their initial entry
training be that in the Air Force or the
Army Air National Guard currently the
incentive payment is at 500 it's not
really making the difference that we
hoped it would make the second component
of that bill is that it eliminates the
requirement for rule making there and
the justification there was rulemaking
generally applies when we talk about
rules that apply to the entire
population the specifics this specific
program only applies to current and
former members of the New Hampshire
National Guard so we wanted to to to do
away with that and off the top of my
head uh representative I can't remember
the third piece of it uh oh I know what
it was it was to I do remember now Judy
just kicked me under the table so I knew
it was going on it was uh the third part
of that bill is to allow for the monies
that are collected based on fines for
non-judicial punishment to be applied to
this fund as well so we've asked for a
fifty thousand dollar appropriation in
this year's budget we'll talk we can
talk about that as we go through the
budget but then again any other uh
non-judicial punishment that is levied
against soldiers for for disciplinary
actions also be applied to this fund in
the past the non-judicial punishment
fines went to the scholarship fund so we
had a New Hampshire National Guard
scholarship fund and when we did away
with that to create this recruiting
incentive fund and roll this program
roll the the Appropriations into this
program we just didn't clean up the
language and the statutes to make sure
that that money followed so we wanted to
make sure that we were able to allocate
those that money as we go forward so
those were the three provisions of House
Bill uh 3 30. again in the in the
governor's phase of the budget we met
our Target and we kept we asked for that
appropriation to be increased from
25 000 in the last biennium to fifty
thousand dollars in this biennium uh and
again that you know that this program is
contingent on the will of the will of
the general court to approve that in the
budget now I see we met with uh sponsors
on March
third and shows that they came out of
the committee of
Federal Federal relations and Veterans
Affairs 13-0 when it passed on voice
fold yes I I have a check mark on my
page so I think we may have already
acted on that I know that I know that
Miss Aaron zayak was here last Friday to
testify and her report to me was that
you guys were all in favor so I was
pretty happy about that so I'm happy to
answer any other questions you may have
about it I guess we're good then fifty
thousand dollars a year
of General funds another year once we do
have an amendment to add this language
to House Bill 2. okay yeah yeah it's
filled up to fifty thousand dollars a
year
yeah okay but you have to allocate the
all right I guess we're good see but
that's that's good so good again members
of the committee uh good afternoon thank
you for the opportunity to speak to you
this afternoon as we discuss our state
operating budget uh for the Department
supporting a note that we have a
matching federal budget and they're
complementary to each other so without
without the state support to this the
National Guard really can't accomplish
all of its missions the two budgets have
to complement each other or it will have
an adverse impact to our mission our
current proposal for our in our
operating budget submission is prudent
reasonable meets the governor's
efficiency budget targets and we kept in
mind our two overarching objectives and
this is in your written testimony that I
passed to to Mr Hoffman supporting the
200 million dollar federal budget at the
state level and providing by providing
facilities support to the men and women
of the New Hampshire National Guard and
supporting our state's veteran Community
by providing the necessary resources to
the state veterans cemetery the division
of Veterans Services and the division of
community-based military programs
you know on the on the I won't read the
whole testimony but you know in terms of
military Affairs and our facilities in
modernization over the past couple years
we've been able to bring in about 143
million dollars in federal money to
support the facilities uh of the
National Guard including our Edward
cross training complex in Pembroke both
the Hooksett and Rochester field
maintenance shops new armories in
Pembroke and Concord and new buildings
in Concord on the state Military
Reservation
up next we're looking at a new field
maintenance shop in Littleton a new
Armory in Plymouth in additions to our
Milford and Nashua Readiness centers
we're also working through uh getting
approval to build an aviation facility
training facility in Berlin we have the
appropriation of federal appropriation
to do that and we're working through the
process to make sure that we have the
land so we can build a hangar up there
and that will be primarily focused at uh
power management Aviation training in
the White Mountains and it'll also you
know that's what that's why the federal
government has given us the money but it
also will support search and rescue
missions which we have done a lot of in
the last couple a couple years to pluck
people up out of the White Mountains
so we do we do need to have you know we
have a tremendous operating costs
utilities snow plowing Grounds
Maintenance some of our facilities are
aging uh HVAC Electrical Plumbing
maintenance fire alarms burglars all of
those things that are required to to
keep the National Guard and Facilities
that are that enable us to support both
the state and federal missions on the
verit service size of veteran services
side we have minimal changes to our our
uh existing portfolio veteran programs
but we do have the state Veteran
Cemetery division Veterans Services and
the Division of Community Based military
programs all of these are providing uh
essential services to the veterans of
the State of New Hampshire clearly uh
the state Cemetery provides a dignified
resting place for our our veterans uh
and if you haven't been there it is
unbelievably beautiful there and very
well maintained the staff are fantastic
the division of Veterans Services
connects veterans with the benefits
they've earned by virtue of their
service both at the state level and the
federal level they bring in about 170
million dollars in in
compensation to the veterans each year
here in the state of New Hampshire it's
a pretty important part of what we do
and the division of community-based
military programs help with employment
access to housing Health Care college
degrees Mental Health Care all those
things that we continue to do
uh there we do have a mission to have to
provide uh
enduring Partnerships as part of our
mission Triad you know support and
defend the nation uh respond to State
emergencies and build enduring
Partnerships one of the things that is
added this year is a stem program called
Starbase this is a DOD funded program
primarily it's gonna we have about a
thirty thousand dollar line of General
funds to support this program but the
rest of it is about I think it's 70 750
million uh 750 000 I'm sorry got my M's
and T's mixed up uh a year to support
this program this is a stem based
program that will take uh fourth graders
and ex and expose them to stem uh under
the guise of uh you know under the the
control of the National Guard and we'll
contract for those Services here so that
you'll see that addition
in summary uh uh our service men and
women continue to answer the nation's
call both at this uh both here and at
home in fact you may have seen the news
and we're going to send some folks over
to support the Department of Corrections
here for a couple of days uh we continue
to deploy to the Middle East uh We've we
have had in the past year deployments to
Iraq Syria Jordan the United Arab
Emirates we have a contingency that
contingency that's on the Southwest
border now helping uh Customs Border
Protection and you uh US Border
Protection and Customs U.S customs
uh
we have debt we have a dedicated
category of state employees that support
our our men and women in uniform uh and
we're ready to you know we're ready to
continue that support to the best of our
ability uh you know as the as uh the
need arises if you look at the third
page of the written testimony that uh
that we have here those are the
highlights to our changes uh in our
efficiency budget from last year uh and
I'd just like to go over those quickly
with you in case you so you know what's
changed uh from from the last last year
primary uh the first thing is this State
Fire Department that was at providing
fire and emergency services to peas is
no longer a state entity we've we
transitioned that entity into a federal
entity so we're eliminating those
positions it was 100 percent federally
reimbursed money so there's no General
funds to be made there I know that's a
sad face for everybody here but but uh
so but it is it is uh it is the way
we've moved we're going to get about 5
million in federal funds out of salary
and benefits
utilities are a nightmare for us now I
assume for just about everybody else so
you'll see those increases to our uh to
the lines of accounting for our
utilities uh we do anticipate that that
we've peaked in utility cost at least in
the short term and they're starting to
come back down but the bills uh the
bills are substantial so just for the
last
two months three months the last three
months at peace Air National Guard base
the cost just to keep the lights on was
about 285
000 a month
it's a lot of money to keep the lights
on representative McGuire has a question
yeah are you
um upgrading to LED lights and doing
things like that we're doing the best we
can but it you know it's it's we have
done some of that energy efficient stuff
but this this kind of came and got us
right it wasn't something that we were
anticipating we do where we can like all
of my offices have LED lights but that's
peas is a pretty big campus and it would
almost be cost prohibitive in some
instances to replace them at this point
right so the cost to replace the lights
could out at least in the short term
outweigh what's going on and the other
thing to note is that you know 75
percent of that cost is borne by the
federal government as well so it's okay
to save the federal government money I I
was I'm not going to argue the point
representative I'm just saying that even
even to replace them would be I
understand but maybe when something
burns out yes sir we do have we do have
environmental staff in both places and
and our our Engineers are very very good
about keeping
go keeping that uh that in their minds
as we build new facilities I think even
but even more costly to us is the age of
the facilities representative right so
it's not just it's not just keeping the
lights on but it's generating the heat
as well and if the building was is 80
years old you know in brick construction
turn we could turn the lights off and it
uh to continue on that train of thought
you see the thirty thousand dollars
there primarily for Utilities in support
of the Starbase program
uh
we have a 100 federally reimbursed
policy now to have 24 7 on-call service
for some of our Engineers for uh in the
uh in the event that there's a uh an
emergency in the uh in our facilities
after hours again 100 federally
reimbursed Star based program I think I
said 750 000 you can see the line of
accounting there number four
uh
and uh contracts and operating Services
again federal funds to to uh to keep the
our facilities open and in addition to
workers comp
subject to your questions really that's
the those are the highlights for the
changes we have from our previous
biennial budget and again a lot of this
is you know every you know the tag likes
to say when it comes to talk the ad in
general likes to say you know for every
quarter you spend we get a dollar from
the federal government so it's it's it's
good money as long as we're not wasting
the federal government's money and uh we
we uh in our in our efforts to operate
we intend to be good stewards of uh of
the people's money
subject to your questions
questions from representative grassy
Griffin and McGuire basically just a
comment I've been over to the star-based
facility here in Concord my son is the
person who's running that program good
good so for sergeant I know I know he
works right down the hall for me so I'm
glad that's good we haven't beat him up
too bad yet I mean yeah he's keeping his
head above water it's good good
representative Griffin
so I know
you need to refresh my memory because
in in the total funds here the other
funds
amount to over a hundred thousand
dollars and you're not doing bake sales
or anything right no
so here's here's how this generally
works we so for every person that we
bury in the cemetery the the federal
government pays us a plot allowance that
plot allowance is generally about
852 I think this year it's 100.
there's a CPI increase every year right
coming back to me now so thank you so
that that money goes to the operational
cost for the cemetery and we fence it
off so that the cemetery can repair
their equipment and do those other
things but those other funds are
generally there
Reserve McGuire yes thank you Mr
chairman so I'm looking at page 226 in
the budget
which I get I think is the bottom line
and you had quite a big lapse in um
from 2022 to
it looks like right you only spent of
General funds 4.4 million when you're
so we had two we in last in the last
biennium budget we had two-year money
added in house bill to for in support of
veterans social isolation and uh uh
mental health so we executed the first
half of that so that the remainder of
that lapse is part of that 1.5 million
dollars
so that's but that's coming back in yeah
yes it absolutely is coming back in this
year we don't want we don't want to have
put these programs out right and then
not you know and then and pull the
carpet out for the pro and the the
programs that we started so uh and right
now we have two contracts for about I
think it's eight hundred thousand
dollars four hundred fifty thousand
dollars to Easter Seals and 350 000 to
uh to the partnership for public health
so they're they're increasing their
staff to be able to to uh
provide services to Veterans Mental
Health Services and social isolation
services and increase networks across
the state so that that's the first part
of that money has been spent we have
another year on that on that that's not
a difference of millions right that's it
so
here's what I'm looking at so first of
all
according to this you got
um close to 20 million of federal funds
in 2022 but for this year and and the
subsequent years you're expecting more
like 33. so that's like a 50 increase or
something like that it's very big
oh yeah so that's what I asked you so
the other thing that happened at the end
of covid right was the Federal
Government waived their Federal match
the state match uh okay so so the the it
wasn't like we didn't spend money we
just didn't spend general fund money
nice so and then so that money is going
to come back
okay one other thing so I'm I'm a former
member of division three
and the one thing that always surprised
me was that the Veterans Home is all
General funds yes it can you explain why
or so veteran fund the vet I I don't
want to speak for the commandant of the
veterans home so I'll have that caveat
first the veterans who had all kinds of
veteran services but but the Veterans
Home is not part of the Department of
military Affairs and veteran services
and generally when I get asked that
question I answer it this way the
Veterans Home is a nursing home that
houses veterans not a veterans home that
is a nursing home so we have no
expertise in the department on running a
nursing home so it's not part of of what
it is that we do here so I uh I mean
that's the best answer I can give you uh
I don't again I can't speak for her
budget but so I know they get some they
get support from the VA and I know and I
know some of the
some of the cost is borne by the
residents through their VA compensation
but beyond that sir I I'm reluctant to
answer your question do you have any
idea what other states do along those
lines
uh it's not something I've looked into I
really pay more attention to the the VA
compensation and claim pieces in terms
of other states uh and the cemeteries in
terms of other states because I and then
I try to stay I mean I have enough to do
frankly without having to do the veteran
home piece too I would imagine that it's
a mix across the country if I was if you
had put a gun to my head and made me
answer the question I would say some
states roll it all up into their
Department of Veterans Services and some
states keep it separate we're unique and
not unique but uh in this state we have
those veteran services co-located with
the National Guard other states have
them co-located with the National Guard
and in addition have Emergency
Management so director Buxton would be
part of the adjunate generals piece and
they call them super tags uh but uh I
would say some probably have it done
that way and then they're separate from
the National Guard it's a separate a
separate piece yeah I'm just thinking
that because you get you know three to
one four to one federal funds they get
zero you know so somehow if it was moved
into your area you know you know
in that light I would say the funding
sources wouldn't change for the veterans
home if they were us the federal money
that we get in support of it all of it
is in support of the National Guard none
of it is in support of federal Services
okay so all of our veteran services are
100 generally funded except for the
income that comes from plot allowance
from the VA and that would be the same
as rent for the residents of the the the
the better I think so if you ask the
question that way is this not going to
change and we can't and frankly and to
be uh just to put another point of
clarification and precision on it
the the way the federal government
controls that spending is not by a
grants officer that's at the Department
of Transportation in Washington D.C we
have a United States fiscal and property
officer who sits on our who's a federal
employee sits on our uh our compound
he's substantially involved and make to
make sure that the money that we spend
is allocatable and uh and appropriate to
what we do and we to the penny it's it's
what drives Miss Chen crazy because he
is right in our Hip Pocket every day so
if we tried to spend it wrong we'd
catches
okay representative cambrells thank you
Mr chair and I'm sorry if I missed
something along the way but
um and the total number of positions at
the very end you're going down from 163
to 128. could you talk to that and then
also uh the overall expenditure amount
budget it doesn't go down by very much
but yeah you're going down by a
significant number of positions could
you explain that so the number of
positions are the firefighters that I
referenced in the piece those those
Federal firefighters so that's that's it
uh 30 35 of the firefighters are being
abolished and then uh
so that's it and they were so
yeah that's those were the numbers they
said so okay so and and then uh this
you know part of part of the there's no
general fund decrease because they're
100 Federal reimbursed
and deserves so Melissa Mr hopping those
are the house bill wine abolishments we
saw talked about earlier
I didn't have to double check but that's
what they were that's where they would
appear when they're removed from the
state system would be in house bill one
back in budget
question from representative evil so I
was curious about the veterans cemetery
do you have plenty of room there yes yes
ma'am so we have enough undeveloped
acreage to take us effectively to about
so so I think it won't be full before
well certainly won't be full before I
need it
well we're all in the same bracket
except for the youngster over here to my
left
so we have we have plenty of space in
fact we're we're on the phone with the
we had a conference call with the VA
about the next expansion uh attendance
Cemetery job to develop the next acreage
and generally we have we keep on we keep
on developed space enough
for about 10 years is the goal so the VA
will fund the next expansion of the
cemetery to get us to capacity of 10
years and if you're interested in the
projections we're bearing up somewhere
between in the last three years
somewhere between a thousand and 1200
veterans a year and their and their
families it's not all veterans sometimes
it's eligible dependents probably about
800 plots are taken up every year uh so
that's that's about where we are
all right well thank you sir thank you
other well one more question
Almost Got Away yeah
so
are any um New Hampshire
a National Guard in Poland or
starting so there were there were some
in Europe yeah uh there there are
currently I can get you the exact number
so I could send you that current to
current state of where we deploy as a
matter of fact I just forwarded to the
governor's office this morning this is a
normal report I'll be sure to send it to
the members of the committee if you're
interested I don't believe anybody's in
Europe right now I don't believe
anybody's in Europe uh most of the
people are either coming back from the
Middle East or getting ready to go to
the Middle East mostly those folks are
artillery men uh they do targeting and
some other missions uh in the Middle
East and then we have a contingent as I
mentioned earlier on the Southwest
border in Texas
but I'll get you I'll get you the little
sheet unclassified sheet of where
everybody's at that's easy you shouldn't
have asked a question because now I
stimulated a question from me but are
all the deployments federally paid for
it's a rule or yes as a as a rule
deployments in support of the nation's
missions are federally paid for so the
folks that are and not as a rule that's
the way it is right that's absolutely
the way it is so without getting too
deep into it we generally have statuses
we have a state status federally funded
we have a federal status federally
funded
and we have a state status state funded
so the folks that are going to
Corrections uh here in the next week are
estate status ordered by the governor
state funded so those folks that are
going to work in in support of
commissioner Hanks and her folks over
there are that state active duty we call
it
during covid we had two statuses we had
State active duty state funded and we
had title 32 status under the control of
the governor but federally funded and
that was generally under the guise of
FEMA and FEMA's response to the National
Emergency and we go if you're going on a
contingency operation you're on the
border you're out in you know Europe for
example or you're going to the Middle
East that's the president's doing and
the president pays
I think
you guys are awesome because I don't
have to go back to work the more you ask
questions
have any of the equipment that we've
provided to Ukraine depleted your
supplies no nothing like that okay so
and and uh interestingly enough
generally on the federal deployments now
because the theaters are mature right
we're not we're not projecting a force
we're just rotating forces through the
equipment is there so we don't you know
our equipment stays here to to train and
do some things it's it is not
uh
It's Not Unusual for our airplanes to be
in support of those missions right so
the kc-46 refueler Pegasus refueler that
we just you know we just uh implemented
at peace those those planes are flying
real world missions all the time whether
in Pacific at Guam whether they're in
Europe you know pulling fighter aircraft
or other aircraft to the theater of
operations we're doing that flying the
bridge across the North Atlantic to make
sure people have enough you know Jets
have enough fuel to get across those
folks are absolute instruments of war
that we're using you know every day are
we leaving our equipment to go to
Ukraine taking our stuff away to go to
Ukraine the answer is no sir
thank you all right thanks
thank you so much for your time yeah all
right
well I actually have a question I don't
know if this applies to you folks or not
but my understanding was that peas they
built something like a 12 million dollar
facility to take care of pfas is that
you or is that the people that would be
the PDA yes outside so certainly keep it
from worked out that's okay so certainly
the certainly we have an interest in the
the issues with the water contamination
at Peas the division of Veterans
Services has created a registry for
anybody who wants to register in case
the VA declares a presumption so you may
have heard of Camp Lejeune all of those
other things those presumptions of the
water contamination and if you get a
condition listed under those
presumptions then you automatically are
eligible for VA compensation
they haven't done that for peas or any
other place when they do we have people
a list of names that we periodically
update so that we can reach out to them
but we are not doing anything to clean
water up at uh at I know the Air Force
has been and I believe the Big Air Force
the regular Air Force is not interested
in getting involved yet
that's but that's not that's outside of
my pay grade
there we go again thank you thank you
great
yeah
yeah so you everybody okay with this
well once we get through the budget
all right so
do you folks wanna
continue for just a little while or come
back Monday morning it's up to you I
know Mr Hoffman and Melissa would love
to have a few more things to check off
for the so they can keep themselves here
let's see what's 132.
oh yeah so
this is suspended okay approved section
so that's
everybody okay with that show our hands
okay
you know representative McGuire he has a
little list he gives me every day here
but he has fallen behind as far as what
um some reason I have a question mark on
138.
yeah that was I wasn't here for
he did everything else
oh yeah because it was an open-ended
so the deputies of the commissioner
I guess we'd have to look at RSA what
is this a common thing that's just in
the energy in the puc can generate money
from assessments
so it's not it's not that common because
the number of fiscal committee approvals
isn't that broad but
what this language would do would allow
them to
seek fiscal committee
to pay things by increasing the
so I need
thoughts
representative McGuire is saying might
so 38
.
so did you take care of all the public
it's your consumer Advocate Mr chair I
don't think we had House Bill 2 when
they came in before the department of
energy when they came in okay
okay
was that something we should get the
Department of energy back in here or do
you think we can answer these questions
ourselves
we have a little time yeah did they go
through their budget or did they just do
their overview
we maybe just didn't get to this one
right I don't remember going but they
asked for this extra person
and I wasn't that thrilled with it
um
I'm sorry so they asked for this extra
person
um that I guess you see I hear on line
five of page 49. and
um
it didn't seem that that urgence I mean
it was like
to attend meetings or something you know
what I mean it wasn't
um
well yeah because anything in the house
bill too is is in the budget right but
um
I don't know it didn't seem that
line five of page 49 in house bill 2.
three additional staff people not
you're not looking at House Bill 2
so Mr Hoffman went what's the impact to
that I know you
I believe that
position is included in the house bill
one
right it's it's included but in my mind
he didn't make a good enough a very good
if I remember right
he wanted that position to represent New
Hampshire at the
is that like is that a full-time
representative McGuire do you want to
have him come back in or since now we
have no spill two which apparently we
did not have when energies all right
yeah
Melissa Mr Hoffman maybe we could get
them in
yeah and speaking of Monday where we
have just it's in the calendar it's a
work session but I've asked the
department of administrative services
that come in and I think it's nine
o'clock Melissa for 9 30 rather um I
told them 9 30 but I just sent them an
email to change it because I think we're
doing a retirement bill at 9 30 now on
Monday morning so
I switched them to 10 o'clock maybe you
can squeeze in the department of energy
somewhere in the morning there Jeff
so I thought it might be important to
have Das come in because of the employee
pay raise issue that we discussed the
oh
um so next represent employee pay raise
yeah yeah
but I thought that's a no choice thing
well we can separate those in Union
employees out the classified and
non-classified oh I see you see what the
impact is
this and Das needs some time and they'd
so I see you looking at the
representative McGuire is looking at the
bill sheet which we're pretty close to
getting done with
um
so the residential eviction proceedings
do we make it that far that was
House Bill
379. Let's flip it back
oh no I'm sorry that uh
we actually did act I should have looked
at this sheet that was moved by
okay I've got the right list in front of
me so the next bill that we had was 336
which we discussed today I'm sorry 436.
which Weaver as you all know asked for
more information oh here's a good one
that see a solid waste management fund
that we've heard so much about from
representative evil
that's uh
a two million dollar ask
yeah we have not acted on that I jumped
now would they be ready for this money
yes well I mean they have to uh they
have to sort of do the Outreach and set
up the program but yes they're ready for
it and the fund was established
a couple years ago the fund was
established a couple of years ago in
anticipation of EPA funding which as I
explained before the guidelines do not
permit the state to apply for Grants so
they're pretty much ready and they're
very excited at the prospect of getting
this going especially now that we have
the solid waste management plan in place
and one of the goals of the solid waste
management plan was to
get some uh funding uh you know to try
to move ahead on our plan to decrease
landfill usage Etc the other part of
this bill you may recall is that um we
were changing slightly the focus of the
bill to Target
um composting infrastructure development
and it works hand in hand with HB 300
which we have decided to include in the
budget
so I you know I would strongly urge the
division to recommend the inclusion of
this we haven't done much of anything on
Solid Waste for decades and we're being
left in the Dust by all our other states
we want to make sure that continues to
from the song
the soft working group we took a vote to
they authorized me to write to the
division in support of this bill and the
appropriation
thoughts
so the point is that I should put it in
House Bill 2 then or or do we pass it
because it's 2023 number
I thought we could just roll it into the
budget okay
and I just would I'd also say that this
was
um unanimously recommended from uh Ena
and it passed pretty unanimously pretty
much I was listening uh on a Voice vote
out of the house so if we're looking at
it from the policy standpoint it's had
you know thumbs up all the way okay
well if you want to move it I will
second it okay I'd like to move
um I'd like to make a comment
would you settle for a million if we uh
if we run into difficulties here
um well I'm gonna hang tough it too and
hope that uh hope that I mean you want
to have enough so that you can use the
money to help support the infrastructure
and I've talked to the department about
it and the 2 million would be really a
good way of of kick-starting this and
um you know the hope is that this will
get the management the solid waste
management fund going and then they're
going to be going for more Grant monies
and trying to find alternative ways to
um to support the fund and the only
other thing I'll say is that in the
research that I've done with my study
committee
virtually all states have a solid waste
management fund and to support efforts
in the state and we don't
again where I'm coming from is I'm one
of the I believe it's a great
opportunity for entrepreneurs and I
believe in the theory of build it and
they shall come so I'm not as opposed to
having a fund to kind of seed money to
kind of trigger some of these thoughts
but at the end of the day it's up to the
entrepreneurs to to invest in advance
and then and then it will come if you
build it the garbage will come trust me
well the other thing is to help
municipalities that are trying to get
their composting programs going it's
targeted for 50 percent for um food
waste diversion and you'll recall from
our discussions before that our
landfills 25 or more of what's going
into them is food waste and what we
really are trying to do to get our um
to get our landfills to have less stuff
in them is to get the food waste out
like we did with um like we did with the
leaf and yard waste many years ago and
this is just like this really obvious
all right there was a motion made by
representative McGuire no I'm seconding
oh you're emotional I made the motion to
include
um this in the in the budget and amend
hb2
all right everybody
clear and no more discussion the clerk
is ready to call the role please on this
one
all right 462
OTP and motion to retain in the budget
okay representative McGuire yes
representative Griffin
yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Campbells no
representative grassy yes representative
one two three four five six seven to one
all right that being seven to one
um
Mike and Melissa there's something else
oh yeah sure represent Canberra is a
minority Port required or no no not
required thank you and not even
encouraged
well and this is not the final book no
yeah this so this will be recommended to
the full committee when we meet
right but previously we we've also had
to do reports even though it's going to
the next full committee so I just wanted
to be sure I didn't have any
responsibility oh no no no no no no no
not whatsoever and generally that
um because you never know that there may
be a bill that we recommend to the full
committee that represent Maguire will
speak to for instance and committee May
decides a terrible thing so instead of
writing a majority report you'll have to
write a Minority Report but usually it
so what else we have um
so we've acted on
the adult parole board that was ought to
pass
yeah sure representative Sweeney so on
504 we we had heard this last Friday
made a reasonable pitch and we talked
about it as a group and we supported it
then on Monday they came in and with a
on the budget presentation they asked
for another 86 000 to fund a new staff
position that they didn't reference the
need or want on Friday so I don't know
if we can go back to 504 just to talk
about in kind of weigh The Adult Parole
Board stipend increases that they
requested in 504 with their budgets 86
000.
for a new full-time staff position to
support the board and in my head I know
there's it's 30 000 more for the new
staffer but I think it would make more
sense to use the money on a staff
support position than increasing the
stipends by a hundred percent for the
parole board members
um
so I I guess if we can have the
conversation about what we view as more
important
Melissa Mr Hoffman
um
how does this factor in we've got their
request
in House Bill 504 is their conflict
not necessarily no there's no conflict
they're just two different additions to
the parole board
representative so in my mind I was the
other way around in the sense that I
didn't think they really Justified the
extra staff person but but this is for
people that are having trouble finding
right especially the um
well the former member you know bringing
back a former member thing
um because they they want to meet on a
regular basis and and sometimes people
aren't available and they're also having
trouble
um getting someone appointed to the
board right so uh that was my motivation
for supporting
House Bill 504 because
um
these are very experienced people and so
you're trying to sort of call call back
people from retirement right to to do
this work and it's it's there's a lot of
work and it's stressful and so on and
that's why and it's not cheap right
these are people that are normally paid
a lot of money so um
so representative Hewitt you made the
motion a lot to pass and there was
obviously some dissent because it was
seven to two I don't know if you want to
speak to it or
well the the what was going on here
attorney Phillips was talking about was
the fact that
there are I think there are three three
people at some of the time
and
they sit quite a lot
and the problem is that there when
somebody they don't have a back
and I have a backstop they just have the
parole a probe on them so they don't
have any means of bringing back
um
former
retired according authors
so they wind up having having delays
having
pushing things out
double booking things like that and this
was this would prevent them to bring
back a uh a retired
Parole Board member when it's impossible
you know somebody is sick or something
there aren't a lot of these anyway
there's only half a dozen or less
of members and they have to have three
for for rewards so that was my thought
that you know
it's not let's let's get it done Mr
Sheriff yes so thank you for for that
info so because Monday when I had asked
about the two different requests they
had made one through five or four one
through their additional budget requests
to say what do they need more the answer
I remember was essentially a circular
well I need more staff to help the world
board members I need the parole board
members to help the staff but in your
opinion would you say the parole board
actual seating sitting members would
should be the priority over the staff
yeah I think so
you're right they did talk about the uh
the necessity by having somebody on
occasion uh to fill in when a board is
being poor is being created because
there's an awful lot of stuff that goes
into the uh the parole pack
uh that has to be looked up and you know
carpet you know it's a bureaucracy and
uh
that of course would hold things up too
you know but it's it's getting people
extra people to come in when somebody is
out
it's not it's not additional personnel
I was just wondering what excuse what
was the ask for the extra staff person
it wasn't much was it
oh it's one person it was uh with
benefits like 83 in the first year 87 in
the second year and I have that as just
a request that hasn't been acted on yet
right
I don't think the governor put it in
so since you don't have that we did not
respond to the request it's in our list
of things to still consider any more
thoughts representative Sweeney no I
appreciate the Insight from
representative McGuire representative
I think I'm good with with 504 and I'm
up I think I'd be a no on the additional
request
we want to take up the additional
requests now since we're talking about
it representative Griffin
do you have a view any view on the
additional requests for staff for the
they they said they were getting a job
done but it was tight
budget
any more discussion representative yes
and if you did it based on Merit they've
okay so I'm against her again additional
requests
so I'll put it out there's a positive
those in favor of the request hands up
oh
yeah
thank you
the first committee was criminal justice
and Public Safety and they had ought to
pass
20-0
it was a Voice vote on the floor that's
for 504.
what's up
now sounds like
sounds like that boy should have got a
pretty good hearing
but
okay so for their additional requests
for that
staff person
those in favor of that additional
all right so uh what's next
going down the list here 504 that was
one that we held on to as a division
that was the infamous
tunnel in Dairy we had several work
sessions on that
and we did vote to hold on to it the
vote was six to two that's on our
full committee
agenda for next week but we want to up
the recommendation representative
McGuire from yeah hold on to do
something with yeah so I'm against the
the tunnel
um but I think
currently the way it's the way the bill
is written the money is in 2024. so I
think the right thing to do with this
bill is to put the money in 2023 and
then have a vote of the committee itl or
off to pass and send it back to the
floor so therefore it's not part of the
budget it's it's you know because the
main thing we heard from the people
involved in the development was delay is
there is there problem that's right so
we should try to act as quickly as
possible and namely send it back to the
floor let them itl it or send it to the
Senate and so on but I personally will
vote for Ito oh sure
I I think I'm not sure representative
Hewitt made share my viewpoint on this I
know he's made some discussions
to this effect but basically right as it
stands now they have a contract
they have a contract with DOT
and and the town and we're getting in
the middle of that contract and we have
no business being there none
so I would I would
you know I would support emotion or
ideal
okay what we'll do first is we'll take
up representative McGuire's suggestion
to move the uh 800 000 as it's listed
here
for 2024 into
2023 so we'll vote on that first time uh
okay and now I will have a motion to
motion to idea so there's a motion to
so representative McGuire moves can
represents cambrell's seconds to itl
bingo house
yeah
506.
should I know it should be branded in
our brain yeah 506.
you know
biggest file they have here other than
the budget everything yeah that's the
one that damn tunnel so well I think
we're the first committee right we're
not the second yeah
so it could have gone so many other
places some other people might have seen
it
um okay so we're basic so we're going to
take the motion vote on itl
yes yes yeah okay all right
representative Maguire yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative cambrells yes
representative Hewitt yes
representative uh grassy yes
the clerk votes yes representative
leishman yes
okay here we go one two three four five
six seven eight eight zero motion to itl
all right so representative
right yeah yeah this has to be a real
so the other the only other one that we
have which we've had a work session on
is 571
that you may recalls about 84 million
dollar group too yeah do that at the end
I know you have some suggestions yes I
do
um so
this was a very I think this was a
relatively close both right
40 vote difference or something
Mr Hoffman
192 to 167.
so
less than less than 30 both okay so
um
this is a very this is a bill that has a
lot of
um flexibility in the sense that it's
just an extra benefit for a certain
class of employees and so
um
but the reason it's such a big number is
because it's really a very honest bill
in the sense that it's giving this extra
benefit
permanently to this class to this
particular group of employees so it's
it's going to be this year and the next
year and the next year and the next year
so the 84 million is the amount that
that if we did if we just passed the
benefit without any money that would be
the amount the unfunded liability would
increase right so this is to cover the
the the the the the permanent nature of
this of this benefit okay and so
um what's commonly done according to
Carol this with these colas is
that they're not made permanent they're
they're made one time
and in fact uh this group or or a good
part of this group got a cola in the
last budget
so uh but again as a one-time thing not
as a permanent thing and so
one way to cut this down from from 80
million plus to something smaller and
considerably smaller like 8 million or
something or ten would be to again go
one time with this with this benefit
rather than permanent
or it could simply be you say well you
got a cola last year maybe no cola this
year right so you know there's all kinds
of ways to do it we did get a piece of
paper that showed
um back in the days when the stock
market was zooming they were giving you
know one percent two percent colas every
year
um but then since then there's been
hardly any colas
um and this one is a five percent Cola
for a certain group a 10 for another
and so on but but you know you could
change the details of what the group is
you could change the details of what the
cola applies to I personally dislike the
way the bill is written in the sense
that it steps right this group of people
gets five percent that group of people
gets 10 percent lots of other groups of
people don't get anything right and so
you could more you could smooth those
steps and make it more of a ramp
um
if you wanted to to fund this so there's
lots of ways to change it
you know I don't know
um
anyways others can talk yeah yeah
representative Sweeney I'm sorry Mr
chairman oh sorry Melissa oh you go
before all the rest of us sorry I just
wanted to jump in real quick to let you
guys know that Janet's scheduled a work
session on this bill for 9 30 on Monday
morning if that impacts your thoughts I
must have forgotten it just came out
yeah
no she mentioned that Janet that
anything was left that we really didn't
act up while we had to get schedules I
guess I did jump the gun yes represents
Sweeney speaking to that earlier today I
spoke out of turn one of the
representatives I believe from either
fire or police once we were done talking
about 436 ask me just while we weren't
in session if we were taking up any
other retirement Cola bills and I just
said I don't believe so next week uh so
I just want to state that I fine with us
discussing it I I wouldn't want to take
a vote on this either way just because
out of honor to telling them that oh
we're not taking it up there today and
then exactly right so uh I just want to
say that in the record I apologize to
the whoever I talk to that oh we're you
can go home but um we don't have a lot
of bills like this right right
so thank you very much for the record
just just to put an ore in the water uh
it might be a good idea in the process
of since we're not going to do anything
until next week let's take a look at the
language of the bill because when you're
talking about colas there were some some
unions have contracts with the employer
us being an employer nowhere by any any
uh increases that I voted I don't do not
have to you don't have to say in the
bill that it's a permanent thing all you
have to do is say you're increasing the
salaries of such and such people by so
many percent as is normally the case
with that and that just that just
automatically sets off a chain of events
and if that's not what you want to do I
think you ought to have somebody take a
look at the bull Bill and make sure that
it's not it's not just saying something
but it's going to take you 40 years in
the future
yeah I think that's what representative
McGuire was suggesting just like not
going into the future but like at one
time period we had I think was a 30
000 threshold or something yeah last
time yeah when we provided people that
weren't yeah so those people that were
in the lower end if they just got a coal
and those people that hire in go to less
about yeah and it might have advised I
don't know if it applied to group ones
also last time yes yes
for that yeah
Melissa Mr Hoffman do we know what the
total hit was uh
we can lift that up
so we'll have that from Monday and give
us a good idea and maybe I think
representative wire's suggestion is a
good one representative Campbell yeah I
I like representative McGuire's idea
because I think I think it's reasonable
given the current circumstances in the
economy that they get a some sort of
adjustment but one time but as we all
know for our president
um inflation is transitory and it's
going to go away in two years so so we
um yeah and
specifically this is a
I don't have the numbers or I don't know
if we've been told the number of people
in this group but it's pretty small
these are only police and fire who have
been retired 10 years or more already
right so these are for people that are
currently retired 10 years or more and
it's broken into two groups those
retired already 20 years or more and
those 10 to 20. so the 10 to 20s
are getting a 10 a five percent I think
it's a five percent increase on the
first fifty thousand dollars of their
retirement pay so it's not for the the
hundred thousand type people it's for
the you know first fifty thousand and
then the the ones retired 20 years or
more are getting a ten percent increase
on their first fifty thousand so it's
either
um let's say everybody was fifty
thousand it would be a twenty five
hundred dollar a year increase
for the 10 to 20 group and a five
thousand dollar a year increase for the
twenty plus group so it may not or less
right so yeah it may not be hard to
resurrect us because I know we spent a
lot of time in the last budget trying to
work the numbers so if you did something
almost identical we would know pretty
quickly how much it would be and
so Mike I guess Melissa looked for that
bill or what we added to the budget last
time is probably the language is already
there and seemed to work pretty well
it's a one-time payment
are there any further issues
I guess not we'll see you
Monday
please
huh
and just so we'll all know this weekend
um